the people have asked where i am
the answer is right in front of you
welcome to another great edition
of the speeches championship grand prix
i'm grandmaster robert hess here to
bring you the coverage
of what will be an awesome event as it
always is every single tuesday
we see great fighting chess from the top
players in the world on chess.com
today is no exception welcome
to title tuesday that's what the
speeches champion grand prix is formerly
known as
still we call it that from time to time
keep it friendly and we have some great
players participating today you see
at the top of the quote-unquote
leaderboard the tournament has not even
started yet
we have hikaru nakamura sam savion
that's konavets
big fish 1995. that is vladimir ferosev
we have
sasha grishouk mbl you couldn't ask for
a better
cast of characters at the top here so
it's good to be back thank you to
everybody and try to see you there and i
want to
quickly remind everybody of the
standings that we have so i will flip
that on over here real quick
just to remind you of who's doing what
thus far before the game start
parham mag sudlu in first place in the
standings
throughout the grand prix you then have
haik martirosian in second place
followed by hikaru nakamura who does not
need to qualify so you see everybody
there in front of you
and well without further ado we do have
liftoff here hikaru nakamura
takes on the red baron canada
that must be a tough opponent for ikaro
knowing his love for vancouver
in canada not fun to beat somebody whose
username
represents the country that you are
so happy about okay well
someone says hikaru's stream just died
well hopefully he gets that back
and we do see a french in this game with
some tension on d4
you have pawn chain from b2 through e5
and so white tries to be very solid and
then advance with f5 because if you can
play f5
and break open the position the
ambitious play here should favor white
with this knight eventually coming to f4
and they play so quickly i barely even
have time to draw the arrows but you see
that once the pawn captures on d4 you
have a solid punch in here
the tension on e6 the knight coming down
f4 that should spell some trouble
for black and the d4 score is under
white's control
both knights defending the square this
looks to be a great position
for hikaru let's move on because we will
be seeing much more hikaru
throughout the sec gp today
so let's go down the list a bit i want
to get some players that we may not be
able to see
uh in the knockout i expect a car either
to
be in the knockout or in contention for
it that's for sure
so why don't we move to well this is
somebody who actually
may very well find himself in the
knockout it is peter svidler
can't complain whenever svidler is
playing you're always happy to see that
and here's thriller with the white
pieces he is
playing a pretty standard looking
spanish from the white side now what
isn't quite typical is there's a bishop
on f6 staring into
its own pawn on e5 and these knights are
clumsy over on the queen side we see
these knights here they may try to act
as stunt doubles one replacement the
other but that's why a5 was played
kicking this knight from b6
and then this bishop will take on c4
followed up with a quick attack on the
c4 squares the knight has to move
knight ica was played bishop takes
politics and knight a3 does scoop up
this pawn
that should be good for spidler as he
tries to get off to a hot start and
eventually
make his way towards the knockout
so let's see if fiddler does indeed
decide to capture that knight i think
it's a great decision
and there he does it and he's going to
play knight a3 he's winning this pawn
directly c6
challenges the center but thankfully
there's one two defenders of this pawn
on d5
so you may go and take the pawn on d5
but that's not going to amount to all
that much as
well he takes on c6 first then we'll
take on c4 he
is getting an extra pawn here
for his position so great position for
svidler in the opening round let's move
on
just because there's so many great games
going on hell let's go to arjun irigase
because the
indian grand master is one of the
highest rated players
in blitz in bullet pretty much in all
formats on the chest.com server here he
has the white pieces
and i like to see this bishop and pawn
working this way
and isn't bishop takes c5 coming so
that's why
restarting chess wishes he could restart
this game as he is now down in exchange
his king side is in some trouble once h6
g6 happens
having an open age file will be useful
for white and this pawn and c5
well that's still going to be a weakness
so it's not
dead lost or anything like that for
black
but i also imagine argentina will not be
unhappy about eventually swinging the oh
well that's a blunder because this rook
and this pawn are under attack
so just as i was praising arjun's
position he actually makes a big mistake
the rook on h3 directly under attack the
pawn on a2
under threat and the opposite side the
board that is a big miss
by arjun here and he's gonna have to
move his rook and probably move it
say to h2 and that's more of a defensive
move than anything keeping the rook
in line in the second file there uh
second rank i should say
just to defend the b2 square and the
queen side so what i missed
there by by white he said doubles his
rook on the h fun he's going to i guess
queen h2 and try to checkmate on h8 but
the black king will
escape into the e7 square so the point
is after queen h2 if you play move movie
knight c4 rook h8 takes queen takes h8
is not just check it is mate the king is
stuck there so that's why after the
queen comes a2 black
will have to bring this king out from f8
into e7
and thankfully the knight on b6 protects
this rook on c8 so you're not
dropping the rook at the end of this and
i am
oh i don't know if i like that move is
he going to try for b3
he does but origin takes on b3
brings the king to c3 and if queen c4
the king runs to
d2 rook d8 the king runs to e1
and there are no more good checks that's
the claim because
queen c4 king d2 check king here you
don't have c1 you don't have c3 that
leaves b4 but after bishop d2
you have no more useful checks except
you'd have to sacrifice your queen
here uh well it's queen and rook for
queen and bishop that's a bad trade
because rookie had checkmate is
the threat so king c3
now restarted chess is taking his time
here trying to figure it out but now
plays king f8
i don't know if that's what you wanted
there okay well now queen takes
on queen 65
this should be like actually queen f6
check is even stronger because the
knight is hanging here
great move by origin take on b6
and you are up a piece and the king on
d7 is actually weaker than the king on
c3 because there's no useful check this
would be a trade
now you trade queens and that's it what
an exciting game we had here
between these two players at first it
looked like arjun was just going to
cruise then there's this queen e6 double
attack but perhaps i
underestimating the mating potential for
white and now
he's just winning this one no questions
asked
so let's keep on looking here let's keep
on looking let's get ali raisa for ruja
because he has the white pieces in this
game and material is actually even here
the king on h7 is that in
worse shape than the king on c1 i think
at first glance you would think that it
is because the knight on g6 is pinned
but i'm not so sure about that the king
on c1 doesn't really have
true shelter at least not that i'm
foreseeing and well queen of c6 tries to
get the a4 pawn but look at
ali race ago he's teaming up on this g6
square you cannot move that queen away
rook h2 i think this is too ambitious
knight f3
threatens 95 and that actually looks
extremely problematic rook h1 is just a
single check king to d2
do not play king c2 walking in the check
from the queen on a4
and now after queen f6 i guess 95
there's queen to f2 so for the moment
queen f6 looks good and look at how
quickly
alireza shifts his king from the center
of the board over back
towards the queen so what is it wait
what
take it after queen f4 there's knight d2
protecting the rook
i was like what that didn't look right
but i think that alirissa
he doesn't have much time left so he
quickly jumps his king out to b3 where
it's nice and safe
or so he thinks and you can just take
this pawn on b5 instead knight to e5
you're taking a2 now you
are safe and sound over here the g6
knight is hanging
it's falling and so alireza will take
the point here
my gosh queen takes g6 and queen takes
g7 checkmate that
was a really like tough
effort there for real madrid tv
i guess should stick to football at
least that's all the rest is telling him
so let's keep on going here we have
raunek saguani
with the white piece nope
i'm running somebody's the black pieces
excuse me let's put this board around
here these pawns are going that way
so raunak in big trouble here in the
opening game
king a6 now this pawn can come to a5
keep on pushing these things
and now knight d5 check or knight d7 97
took away the c5 square
this two should be winning but
and he's giving up the knight b7
there's oh no oh that's how you blunder
these games away and now it's going to
be a draw because this pawn is under
attack
and i don't think there's a way to save
it because black just wants to sacrifice
the knight here king c8
and that's a draw oh my goodness
raunic sedwani was just
losing and he makes it let's just go
back
for a second here the point of b6 was
after king d5 b7 knight before check
you have to bring your knight to c6 and
then i go a6 a7 and i get my queen
and that is why roundik very intelligent
brought his king to c6
and his opponent must have thought that
he was taking on d5 and that's why he
played b7
but after knight c5 take on b7 it's just
a draw because after a6 knight c5 i'm
sacrificing my knight
for your last pawn it is complete
equality and
that is end of that game missed
opportunity for sure
we go to this game where well duong 57
she is up
three pawns and with a knight against a
bishop this actually is easy just to
march them through
and the king coming into f3 that's the
goal
bring the king to f3 bringing the g-pawn
in or this should do the trick
i don't see any even stalemating attempt
so this is just a win
for the women's international mass
so let's go to uh we can see the
conclusion of this game just to make
sure that there's no
silly stalemates don't play king g3 for
example not by king two
f2 queen okay the king is a skate squad
no stalemate we're good
let's keep on going aha this is actually
important theoretical draw
with the king being so close there's no
way to kick the king off of the f-file
so you just keep this rook here as the
white king cannot get off the h8 square
even here you check so what this king
could even be on the d-file it's still
going to be a draw
but you would need to be able to put
your rook on g8
so this rook can get to g8 but once it
goes there
actually we'll i'll i'll let you see
what happens here comes rook
okay i'd like you to play rook to ga
just to
show what i think is an instructive draw
in the end game here
all right they're just repeating in
other ways
so around here
the point is that you can just move your
rook away as you do not want to trade
that loses the game because then the
pawn promotes
you just move your rook anywhere and
after check your king goes back to f8
you keep this king boxed in
and as soon as the rook comes here you
can just bring your rook back so that
there's no checks
okay moving on it looks like we are
getting into the second round
we have flawless fighter taking on
hikaru
ikaru with the black pieces in this game
and he plays a scandinavian so john
bartholomew if you're playing i don't
know if you're watching
probably not but either way eat your
heart out buddy because this was
team scandi hikaru's on your side
my friend so here in this game you have
a very solid position for black with the
pawns on b7 c6 and f7 e6 what that does
is limit the potential scope of white's
light square bishop
and you make sure that white cannot push
this pawn forward
so even though white is securing the
bishop pair after knight to g6
after h6 g6 this bishop on e2 it's not
really the most promising
bishop that you could get and that's why
i first mentioned
these pawns on b7 c6 and f7 e6 because
they work
really well against the enemy light
square bishop and
most often in these lines black has to
give up this light square bishop in
which case white is the only player with
one
so okay castling queen side this is a
way for aicaro to
have kings opposite sides of the board
so perhaps he can launch an attack
although a4 played here is saying that
perhaps white's attack is first and will
you play a5 to threaten a6
or will you try to play for b4 and b5
breaking open
the queen side that's your goal the rook
on d8 is well placed against a queen on
d1
eventually e5 or c5 type of moves will
look
pretty nice for black so you have to
time it right
but that's the goal here
and all right so b6 played this
makes the c6 square a little bit more
vulnerable that is
a potential problem for black but at the
same time this pawn on a6
well it looks good for now giving up
some check mating ideas it could be a
problem in the future as it has wandered
quite far so
in end games that pawn could become more
of a liability than an asset
and the bishop came to f3 this is a
well-played game thus far for white here
she has taken over control of a large
part of the board
and e5 is what hikaru is going for
it remains to be seen if i'll be able to
accomplish that and actually can you
play bishop g2 and queen f3
and use this diagonal and the point that
i'm trying to make here is not just that
this pawn on c6
is under attack let's say we just do
something
like this i have knight b5 it's not just
under attack it's pinned
because of the checkmate on the a8
square so lining the queen and the
bishop up
on the diagonal looked really powerful
and while we saw
b5 played by hikaru 94 and king
to c8 he's in big trouble here i feel
like
if white just plays very normal looking
moves like trying to break open the
queen side
that looks like the way to go and now is
e5
possible because if that move is
possible it's the move you should play
otherwise your position is in big
trouble but hikaru
is looking like he's in some rough shape
here if i was the only move that defends
the c6 pawn
and after e5 there will be a series of
mass exchanges here
and well i don't know if the car is
getting what just bishop takes c6
take that pawn that's a that's a freebie
over there
and that threatens bishop b7 checkmate
now you can take this rook
but i don't even think i would take the
rook i i don't know how do i continue
this attack maybe rook
a3 to go rook b3 or rook c3 something
like this
getting the rook into play this bishop
is stronger than the rook you don't need
that rook
you can take it and be very happy but i
do think that the attack
is worth it instead of just going for
the material go for the attack keep up
the pressure
she does take on e8 and that's still
good for white
but for hikar at least you feel a little
bit better now that you have control of
some of these light squares
here comes the knight to d5 threatening
to take this bishop also perhaps bring
the knight into c3
queen of d2 that's actually a very good
move by
white trading off the queens here
and well how to break through now that's
the question how do you get a move like
c4 in
not going to be so quick because the
rook comes to c8 but perhaps you can
play c3
and then bring your rook double them and
then play for c4
so she puts her rook on e2 and a car
brings the knight into c3 so that's a
smart move
trying to take back with this rook and
play against this pawn on c2 then bring
this knight into d5 so
essentially you're keeping the position
as closed as possible
from the enemy rooks and posing some
direct threats here king c6 protect your
pawn on b5
hikaru is well ahead on the clock and
right now up a minute but down in
exchange in a pawn
not the most ideal situation however
here goes that pawn a6
i told you in the end game it's going to
be a weakness here comes knight to b4
hitting the pawn on c2 a second time and
well do you want to give up this pawn
not really but she decides too because
if knight takes two then d5
just trying to get active here
honestly since hikaru
lost that c6 pawn and the exchange right
after he's been playing very very well
here
and look at this now it's a knight in
one pawn
for rook and black has stopped white
from playing d5 and if that move is not
possible
that's really going to be a problem
uh for her because look now we have an
outside pass pawn
that's looking to roam okay so that's a
very good move
attacking these two pawns here so f6 was
played
rook to h1 i liked rook h8 being more
active instead she
retreats her rook to the first rank and
okay so c uh knight c7 protects the pawn
e6 very well
honestly this is not easy for white to
even come up with individual moves here
g4 is g5 and that way you kick the rook
and play f4 next
and the d4 pawn is hanging so actually
rook takes d4 right
now instead taking on g4 the problem
we're taking on g4 is king g3 king takes
g4 the king gonna start playing
uh pac-man and go for the
pawns on the side of the board and here
here they go
so hikaru is going to play knight to b5
and try to get the d4 pawn
but she's going to go and take g4 and
then g5
i believe at least okay rook to
e3 didn't seem entirely necessary
curious decision she's playing for a
draw at this point there's
no way that white can even hope to be
better and she has 13 seconds left
so hikaru can play for a3 but then
rookie 5 and rook takes b5
and that way the pawn will be captured
on a3 so that's i think her best
and easiest chance to just make a draw
so knight c3 hikaru avoids that watch
out for forks oh 94.
okay king takes g4 king takes g5 you
escape so knight takes f2 as card plays
to not just liquidate and make an easy
draw so what
she should do is don't play rook g4
because 95 check that's a big mistake
play king e3 good move
you want to well actually this just
makes your life
rook g4 and now take on a4 she is able
to
withstand the pressure and now it's
hikaru who probably has to prove
that he has the draw but he does because
rook check came to b2
you take this i take this so it's just a
trade and she does that that's very
smart by her
and the game is a draw i'm glad we
stayed here because that was a real
battle
and hikaru nakamura gets nicked for half
a point in the second round
let's go to sam sebian he has the white
pieces in this position he has a knight
for a pawn this should be a draw with
proper play but i can envision a
position
where this king gets in some serious
trouble some mating net
potential and the rook comes to a2
that's really good play
by victor scalia of here just shuffling
the rook
on the sixth rank now rook to b2 then
the king would be forced back the king
is fourth back anyway
but you've walked into a pin here so
rook h6 there's no easy way
to threaten checkmate this rook is just
checking the white king from all over
the place
and if you go knight e5 you take away d7
but you don't take away b7 so the king
can
choose its side and i do believe that
this
should be quite a straightforward draw
for black you just keep your king on b7
and keep on checking away oh okay well
actually this is getting scarier this
mate
as soon as i said jigs commentators
cursed it's checkmate rook b8 is coming
oh my gosh i regret it i'm sorry victor
i'm sorry so what happened is he walked
white's king
to b5 he allowed it to be five there's
no check on b6
knight is here and this exact mating net
is happening so after rook h695
only move if you don't sacrifice the
rook only move
and that's a checkmate victor i'm sorry
i'm sorry oh my gosh
my bad i'm so sorry dude
we're gonna move on we're gonna pretend
that didn't happen we're gonna pretend
that didn't happen we are now
instructive rook and pawn uh versus
rook end game here let's flip it from
white side of things so you do not want
to allow the king to come to h6 but even
if you do
with the pawn on g6 there's no
opportunity to kick the king away
because
you okay if you checked here the king
would come to h8 so here the king comes
to h8
and this doesn't threaten anything so
the king can shuffle back and forth and
as soon as you play g7 i always can
check you on the sixth rank
so that's really the issue and so if you
play for g7
which i think that white will eventually
here it is you just keep your rook
go back and forth just go back if the
rook leaves the sixth rank then you have
a check
otherwise there's no threat because the
rook covers the entirety
of the final rank
wait what oh it's stalemate i was like
did somebody just blunder something
okay that's a very funny position just
to show that one more time
so rook a6 if you take it stalemate so
the rook came back and
well going back and forth do not take
this rook on
f6 that was instructed though check
now you take it stalemate and why that
was so instructive was
if black took on f6 king takes this
loses
for black because here the king comes up
and i get a queen
so you have to be careful not to just
trade uh thinking that it's going to be
a straightforward draw okay and well
we have round three we see some of our
leaders
not too surprising to see players like
fedo seyev arjun arigacy we have
andreikin
that's vladimirovich you have andrew
tang that's the penguin gm
alireza faruja that's and then we have
nordiarbeck abusatara
so many strong players there at the top
grandmaster after grand master
playing in this event and of course
there are
some non-gm's who have a perfect
two-and-oh start
and we will continue to see the games
and right now in this position between
indian elephant
and conovets against sam7 is conor vets
you have these hanging pawns and
the problem with these pawns is that
they don't protect one another so if
this knight comes to a4 as it just did
now the pawn c5 is under attack and so
the knight comes in e4 that's a very
good way to defend here comes the knight
to d2
trying to kick this knight out of e4 so
i can win your c5 pawn
so this is thematic play for
white against the hanging pawn structure
you want to keep
putting pressure on these pawns and if
you ever play a move like c4 you give up
control of the d
force whereas the queen f5 threatens f2
while protecting the knight on e4 and if
you took on e before the
pontes queen f3 is away saying if you
take on f3 i take with my knight
and that way i am not hanging my knight
but there is a problem on the b3 square
so i would probably try to take and play
rook to b8
but the issue is b4 happens and the pawn
on c5 is pinned
to the knight on c6 and if you play c4
this is the problem with the hanging
pawns
you give me control of the d4 square and
i will gladly take advantage of that by
putting my knight in right away
so queen f3 knight a5 was played and
that's a good move because you are
threatening the opponent b3 with the
knight and now before
you can just take it and you can take
twice
so black is actually up a pawn here
and white has good central control at
least that's the claim
but what sevien is doing is he's using
his pawn on d5
to get both of his knights forward here
and so the extra
pawn should make its presence felt for
the long term as it's an
outside pass pawn it's not just upon
sitting
say on like e6 where it is a good extra
pawn
but it's has the potential to become a
real passer and actually watch out
knight b6
and d5 hangs whoa how did that turn
around so quickly
i was just talking about this a5 pawn
and i guess
sevien sort of underestimated this
bishop c7 knight b6 type of idea
and that means maybe taking on i don't
know it's actually
kind of a tough position so we get here
we're now with material equality
and from seven's point of view he's
still doing perfectly fine
but white does have more control over
the board and the knight on a4 is
annoying because it stops your past pawn
it blockades it so let's let's keep on
moving we'll maybe come back to this
game but for now
we'll go for the first time to vladimir
fetoseyev's
game he is big fish 1995. he certainly
is no fish
uh though he uh has that username he is
just
incredibly strong player and the rook
came to e7 in comes the knight to d6
and you have to watch out for queen a4
knight takes b7 and this bishop on g2
is hitting this knight on c6 that's one
of the main ideas
of bringing your knight into d6 it looks
good it kind of cramps black position
but there is a tactic on the b7 square
in many different variations
and the queen a4 jump is pretty natural
so i actually do not like black's
position at all i think that
white is objectively in like this
position
it should be really easy to play and so
at like a higher level
like sort of classical level chess type
of
thought people would say oh this is just
a win for white of course in blitz
anything can happen but the position
seems way too easy for white to play
and now after bishop d7 plays b4 there's
no useful knight discovery
and now uh after
a6 well there are several options you
can play for b5 if you'd like but i like
this move bishop to d5 looks better
because the
light squares on this king side are
looking weak and they're two separate
diagonals so
queen to b3 it takes away the
a2 g8 diagonal and then this bishop can
just slide right back to e4
and if you put bishop e4 and black has
to play f5 you've
loosened your control over the e5 square
this pawn chain here
looks very strong and it's needed to
defend the center
but bishop e4 could induce the move f5
and further weaknesses and f5 was played
voluntarily but b5
here just looks oh we
could not be me enjoying this position
for black
no look at these pieces just
perfectly take you can take on b7 and
just
win that pawn this is going to happen
take on b7 and play for c6
yeah that's that's no fun you don't even
have an attack
that's the problem is you would like to
go for a checkmate but here's c6
white's pawns are way too quick in this
position so it looks like
ferocious is going to win this game
i cannot imagine a fusion position where
he doesn't
just go on to easily convert this but
maybe there will be a sacrifice here and
then f4 f3 kind of
attempts to you want to mate on the
g2 score so if you get your pawn and
your queen lined up that would be a
checkmate that takes a long time
and here queen to d5 if f3 the queen
checks
on e4 and can swing over it to the king
side to help out and if queen to h3 the
queen can go back to g2
offering an exchange of queens and
saying well you can't really checkmate
me with my queen's on g2
so very precise play here by fedo say
all is looking good for him so let's
move to another game while we have time
we have uh lamb lay that's um
from vietnam been over 2 700 for so many
years now
super grand master one of the best blitz
and rapid players on the planet
and well in this position he is up a
pawn from the black side
and now root takes f2 and we have
opposite colored bishop so for some
they may think well that should just be
a draw but for
black in this position now you have a
past pawn so it's an
opposite color bishop dynamic with
an extra pawn in the center and first
centralizing the bishop
trying to get after this pawn on g3 do
not trade the ropes as soon as you trade
the rooks
it makes white's life much easier in
terms of holding this position
so rerouting the king into the center
does make sense don't hang your bishop
d6
it's a good move and it looks like i'm
going to actually go to the federation
really quickly because knight takes h6
check wins the queen
i just wanted to get back there as i saw
the conclusion about to happen
he put his king on h2
white cannot take this rook without
checkmating ideas
immediately so that's why i took the
rook and put his queen on e4
and that was all he needed so back to
this endgame here with lamlay
winning by resignation wow surprised to
see that but
the resignation happened because
there's no really useful move if you
play king h2 black plays f5
if you play rook g5 black can just play
king f6 but look at this move f4
be alert for tactics it may be an end
game but there still
are tactical possibilities because if
you take on f4
in comes my bishop with check and check
to your rook
so that i guess is why white resigned
here i would not have resigned
definitely not i would have continued
playing
but in he said i have enough i don't
want to be ground down it's not fun for
me
here's your point we'll move on to the
next game
good technique though by ma'am let and
let's go to on draken's game whoa
it is a draw by repetition that is a
black king
trying to help this pawn promote i was
like wait is that a king on b8
whoa that's a king on g1 over here and
the
way this was a draw was the knight came
to g3 you cannot take on g3 because
after king takes g3 i win your pawn
and the b pawn promotes so after knight
g3 king g1
now if you play a move like b6 well
that's a big problem
because i can take your knight and after
king takes h2
b7 queen queen me and
there it is there's a skewer
but behind the king on g3 is this queen
on b8 thank you for your queen
i win the game and that is why they just
made a draw with
knight e2 and back to g3 they just
agreed on a draw in that manner
that's precise play for you let's keep
on going let's go to
dimitri colors here he has the white
pieces
and he's playing a brazilian grandmaster
this is going to be a draw because black
is going to sacrifice the rook for the
f-pawn
white is going to sacrifice his rook for
the
oh my gosh i smoked too soon and i
jinxed it i jinxed it
white is going to win this game oh my
gosh it's the second time now
i know danny's like oh the commentator's
curse isn't real but it clearly
is real because this king is going to be
checkmated first that's what's going to
happen here
okay be careful not to like hang a piece
but rookie four queen f3 is good and if
queen to c3 you just take it and this
rook is hanging instead we have
oh my gosh i'm the worst somebody fire
me
somebody get rid of me oh my gosh
i feel so bad you have to play rook f8
immediately and take this pawn
that's what you need to do just give
your rook up for this pawn
and then use your king to help your
a-pawn promote where the white rook will
have to sacrifice
instead he brought his king in first and
after rookie eight the f pawn
is promoting and so we saw what happened
when you promoted this
it looks like the same time but white
was first and that means you get to
check
this king and it was very quick finished
if queen of d4
there was rook to e4 there is a pinned
queen
you will get um your rook against a
queen which is
a winning position theoretically for the
side with the queen but oh
my gosh let's move on next round we have
sam
sevin with the white pieces against
grandalicious
that is nilsgrendelius from sweden and
this position is one where white has
sacrificed the pawn there is no d4 pawn
usually you have a pawn chain here
instead seven has given up that pawn for
very quick play there's an attack on the
pawn on h7 you need to move that pawn
now this bishop can come to f4 and this
rook can come to d1 and rook to e1
it's like really awesome to have this
kind of position for white you don't
care about the material
because the extra pawn is one of these
two so the presence
of that extra pawn isn't so meaningful
just yet here comes rookie to d1
and if you take on f4 i bishop h7 check
and i win your queen
for my rook so it is going to be
a bishop a rook and a pawn for queen
that is lasker compensation
and that if you just do the math rook is
five my bishop is three
pawn is one that's nine versus the queen
that's nine so that sounds pretty good
from a mathematical theoretical
standpoint the problem is
when there are so many more pieces on
the board it's about the safety of the
king
and this oh my gosh i'm taking that i
feel like that has to be the move
they're not my pieces so i'm okay
sacrificing but bishop takes g6
giving up my bishop for two pawns and
landing my queen on that square
with threats of taking on h5 and taking
on f6 that's so tempting and if not
take on c8 put your queen on e4 you
improve the position of your queen
in it comes to e7 hitting f7 hitting b7
hitting f6
because they're not my pieces i'm happy
to sacrifice
but look at what sevien does he's like
hey robert can you stop that man
those are mine not yours don't give them
up bring the queen to the center
and now queen e7 is a big problem so
look at this queen of d4 centralization
hitting bishop hitting pawn the way to
protect that pawn would be
bishop would you see a resignation
because bishop e7
there's rook to e1 well now your bishop
is under attack
so what would you do because you can't
move your bishop here then there's rook
to e8 check you move your bishop
anywhere else
i just take your opponent f6 if you play
rook to d8 i
swing my queen to c4 now your bishop and
your other f pawn are under attack
you're just
dropping pawns left and right and it's
going to be
a devastating position so sam savion is
looking to be
in the best shape possible right now
he's really playing
an excellent day of chess thus far and
we have this position between alexei
sorokin a feed a master who's
i believe his rating is above 2500
feet a so he's pretty much grandmaster
strength if i'm not mistaken
and he just happens to have the feeding
master title he does not have grand
master strength internet connection i
see
two bars here for him he may want to
work on that
and he also just lost a pawn on a4 and
black is about to play b5
so arjun stole the pawn
okay i thought that the knight was
hanging i didn't even realize the queen
was here but i still don't really love
this decision because
now you have the bishop pair and there's
a pawn in e6
so i was just thinking that there was a
piece that was going to hang but here
bishop c4
switching diagonals for the bishop looks
pretty smart and pile up pressure on
that pawn
rook after d1 i don't really buy it
perhaps there's c4d5 in the future for
sorokin
that must be his idea
but rook on d1 i would have rather work
on e1 especially look what he did
bishop c4 so unless he's playing to go
d5 which does not work in fact that
blunders right away thank you for the
double attack on your
queen and bishop so you can't play
d5 alright so bishop a2 was played
instead and
even if you do play d5 you're opening up
the position
for both sides it's not just white's
bishop on
a2 and rook on d1 that will benefit from
this d5 move
you see that the bishop on f6 already
says hey please do play d5
because your pawn on c3 will be a target
so rook a to b1
first putting pressure on the b7 pawn
black can play b5 just to make sure that
pawn doesn't need to be
defended so much and
knight came to a5 all right so this is
protected
this is threatened you want to play c4
but knight would take on c4
so bishop f4 played now b5 interesting
position i'm going to keep on looking to
see if there are other
games that we may want to attention
let's go to penguin gm
oh i don't know exactly how much we want
to look at this game
but penguin gm taking on quezon
roman and this is looking like a london
system very closed position but this
move a5 was a good one
because if you played b5 at any point
your pawn on c5 is not defended so
took on b6 first 90 takes on c5 if king
takes e5 you can even
take this knight on a7 if you'd like
because after rook a7 king b6 would be
the way
to attack the rook and defend but rook
a4 hits both of your bishops at the same
time
be alert for retreating moves that also
attack something
so king b6 not okay here you have to
do something about your bishop probably
bring bring it all the way back to
c7 and then after rook takes the pawn on
b7 bring your king back to d6 not ideal
you've lost the pawn
but you do have the bishop pair and that
should help you in your quest
to try to make a draw on both sides in
really big time trouble here andrew tang
down 21 seconds he is one of the fastest
players in the world we know that
from all of his hyper bullet uh games
his prowess there is really unmatched
almost so here comes the king to c5
and well what is he going to do he takes
and he's trying to b4 now he has
an extra pawn that is a past pawn it has
moved forward to b4 watch out for e5
it's going to be
pretty annoying but if you play e5 you
do lose control of the d5 square
so i guess that's why andrew is okay
with it rook a1
is the idea of trying to get into a6
with not just a little bit of a check
but they're also
potential mating nets this is why kezen
brings the rook
down probably rook coming to a2 maybe e5
as well okay and then i came to c2 so
this is
really solid for white can't take on h2
don't go full fissure
rook h1 and win one of your bishops
there
and kez and you gotta move
okay so e5 is e4 even a threat i'm not
sure it is but e4 played anyway
takes takes and we've seen some trades
which
are helping white in the position
because now you have two pass bonds
and c4 was played f5
watch out for c5 check winning the rook
okay brings the rook back but
yeah this is a check this pawn is
pushing and
white wins on time anyway nicely done by
andrew tang
let's go to vugar pursue love against
whoa what's happening here fedo sev
he has the black side of this position
and he just stole it knight but his
opponent is queen
so black has a million pawns but no
queens
so this is just king c3 only chance
hoping that your opponent misses rook to
a1 check okay king c4 doesn't
really help you can't go king d3 because
takes your queen
takes on b5 you're not done a quick
queen e2 check
i'll quick even better and fedo sev goes
down to
rasulov here that means that
federsev still has plenty of opportunity
to win the rest of his games
and make the top eight you know remind
everybody the top eight
move on to
the knockout and rook b3
this is just an even position
we see that black is
keeping the king connected with the
pawns
and even though white's pawns are a
little bit more split you can't easily
attack both at the same time the king f3
king g3 and
well we just see a draw
so let's uh let's look at
our friend raonic subwani who drew that
first game miraculously
and now is sitting at two and a half
three he has the white pieces he does
have an extra queen
he also has a checkmate idea if king to
c1 so
he wins his game here
and let's go back to argent erigacy oh
he won
so let's not go back to him as his game
is over
and just have a few more games left and
after this game we will have
a break because after the fourth round
and after the
seventh round there is a break
and i'm just looking at some messages
from uh the chess.com team
they're like after this round you get a
break go just kidding you're already
fired
like okay well i guess that's that's on
me because i fired myself
oh no we have work against rook one of
these games that go on for 150 moves
for no good reason so make the draw
make the draw just do it
come on why
why do they always do this
i think somebody should offer up their
rook
just like put your rook on c4 and play
rook c2
well not with your king over here i mean
just why they got to do this
ah they just love to
torture everybody else although at this
point because
there's going to be a break no matter
what it gives people a little bit more
time
if they want to stretch their legs make
a phone call
grab some lunch whatever some dinner
okay cool they made a draw by 50 move
role they had to play this out 50 moves
because otherwise they wouldn't have
ensured this was a draw
well on that note four rounds are in the
books we see some of our leaders
on screen our generic gay c jeffrey's
john we haven't seen a jeffrey game
wonderful time min
i'm upset that i haven't looked at a min
game we will certainly look at some
midlay games going forward we have
andrew tang
and well just a number of grandmasters
following it up there
and i guess min is the only non-gmo i
see pravin balakrishnan as well
as a player who's four and up so on that
note taking a break
we'll be back in a few minutes and when
we return we will have round
five of today's speed chess championship
grand prix stay tuned everybody
i will be back shortly
[Music]
so
and we are back and we are in the start
of
round five of the speeches championship
grand prix
title tuesday event and we have si chev
clemente taking on
conovets that's sam savion again and
with the
uh white pieces here you see that there
is a knight on d5 a bishop on e4
queen on h5 it's looking kind of
menacing honestly
and seven plays rook to c5 challenging
this knight on d5 directly
so after queen takes e7 the claim is
that with
the center the knights there have
disappeared
that this should be okay for black
especially with d5 being possible to
gain
more space i prefer black's position
with the bishop pair
i think from an objective point of view
it's
a double-edged position where this
knight is the problem for white that you
would like to have this name e3 this
night we're on e3
i would say that white is in complete
control but because it takes a while to
reroute this knight towards the center i
think the black has the time to castle
get to safety
and be doing just fine and one thing i'd
probably go for here is after
trading castling knight c2 i'd probably
play d4 just to give myself
a pass pawn and
well i would like to have that with my
bishop behind it supporting it
so we have seen a trade on e6 in this
way and then after
castles why not knight to e3 because now
you're also aiming for the f5 square in
addition to d5 but there will be f5 for
black available so that's the
thing that seven is likely relying on
it's why he decided not to
put a white piece and that other
variation there's a white queen on f5
you get his queen e6 that he controls
the f5 square
and will try to push forward so i'm
going to move on to some other games for
now
i see that alireza ferrugia is up
towards the top perfect 4-0 score
he is playing against gukesh who if i'm
not mistaken was the second
youngest grandmaster of all time behind
sergey karjatkin
and farouza just took on c6 gave up the
bishop pair
and the reason why is there is a pawn on
e5 that was just captured so gukesh
he's probably getting himself ready
for all these other big online events
his rating actually has increased a lot
because if i'm not mistaken his blitz
rating on chess.com was something like
as of a week maybe two weeks ago so he's
been improving
his online chess and well he's going to
need every single bit of that
improvement in order to
take on farouja here as black is down a
pawn this knight will sit
on this wonderful d4 square as should be
noted every time there's a knight versus
bishop dynamic
the don't play knight d4 now because
queen takes d4 just to show you that
blunder but what i was going to say
was that whenever there's a knight
against a bishop you want to control
the color complex that is the opposite
of this bishop so you want to get your
knight to d4
because this knight cannot be kicked out
from the square
and google actually doing everything in
his power to take control of the light
squares with a move like
rook to e8 and if i'm white i'm just
playing queen to d2 just getting my
queen
a little bit more active connecting my
rooks with one another and eventually i
would like to play h4 h5
because when you see a fee and keto set
up especially without the fee and killer
bishop
you want to think about running your
pawn of the board and creating some
threats
so let's see let's keep on going to
more games in this round let's go to
jeffrey chong
he is taking on first second
which is a very confusing name who is
this
this is grandmaster nikita meshkov from
latvia so what's going on here there is
a queen on h3 this king on g1 looks open
over here
but what's the material count white has
an extra rook
for a bishop so you see that there's a
rook here for this bishop
and queen takes c5 played no fear by
jeffrey i'm looking at these pieces
and i'm wondering if there's just going
to be
a kind of mating attack but jeffrey says
now you got nothing on me man here comes
queen c8
forcing the queens off the board now you
can even bring this bishop
does that right away brings the bishop
into the attack but how to finish this
off
because queen c8 is there some kind of
bishop takes f2 oh you can't take on f3
i was looking at taking on f3 but
there's a rook here
and i was trying to be forceful i was
trying to do every move a check but with
the rook over there on
a3 that's not working out so now the
queens are off the board
it is a rook and a pawn for a bishop
plus an extra minute and a half on the
clock now jeffrey is
cruising in this game
so let's keep on going so many
top players still duking it out we have
shield 12 who i don't know who that is
let's see that is
shamsidin from uzbekistan and well
taking on his compatriot
uh notre back abuse and
i prefer black's position i think that
the bishop is better than the knight
as i always say a pawn three squares
away
from a knight dominated a bishop does
even more because it's working on both
diagonals keeping the knight
at bay and it's not like
white's position is bad nothing like
that but it does feel a little bit
easier to play with the bishop
especially sitting on
f6 on the long diagonal so c5 played
if this pawn d6 were captured the
opponent c4 would be captured so that's
not what
white wants here and if this knight
moves this bishop can move into one of
these two squares thanks to pawn support
so i would play queen c2 now just inch
your way forward be a pest here the
position
is not objectively even better for black
i would say it's probably level
and e5 is a move to try and liquidate i
think that ultimately is a good decision
because otherwise it felt like black was
making a little bit of progress with
every single move
and
so queen f5 okay can i just move my
knight away
probably like knight to g4 just offer up
some
some trades and here we see trades but
wait rookie three and then
c4 was this a trade in a
bad manner because bishop he said look
at that move here comes the king king f6
uh oh the king is coming right into e5
this is a bad
news for vokirov because f5 at some
moment will also
break the pawn structure but there may
just be a zook swang
because white would like to never move
the knight covers the d4 square the king
protects here
and you have to move one of the pieces
which you do now in comes king d4
in comes king d3 and this pawn is going
to promote
wow what understanding by abusive tarot
here he is winning this game
and there's really nothing oh knight on
a1
uh oh gosh could never be me
wanting that piece there and this bishop
can also help out if needed
by coming to f4 a bishop before check
just wins oh missed it
bishop before won the knight
and there still is bishop f4 you can't
take it
and now you can promote and the king
will take
and this is just winning king to d2 king
to e3
take here actually you don't even have
to you can take here first the bishop
comes to c7
but this is winning a four key takes
well
done by abdu satorov they say that all
these teenagers they don't know how to
play end games
yeah i think that's a mistake abusive
tarot showing excellent technique there
who is steven dettalus
well you just won steven derelus you are
nikola
jukich says ireland
is maybe switch federations at some
point but either way
that's a win thanks to these pawns on a7
and h7
and so your rook can't take one without
letting the other queen in which case
white's just going to mop up the other
pods and bring the rook in to help
a promotion
so
okay king up
king the e6 check king here
and if queen uh queen b6 is checked
and now you can give a check here comes
rook here and you just are oh it's mate
i was thinking queenie i didn't even see
the checkmate nasty
so you're just like inching forward here
and there's nothing that you can do
about this rook because if you go rook
c7 king d6 wins the rook that way
if king e8 queen c6 pins the rook and so
that's just a very
nicely done finish there by
bukowski okay just the last few games
of this round
and this is just a draw opposite colored
bishops you just move your bishop back
and forth
or your king back and forth it really
doesn't matter but they're gonna go
to a billion moves
if i were white at some point i would
consider playing c5 because you can't
lose that anyway
okay they just drew thank you for ending
that game
it was a thrilling finish of course
and i just want to remind people of you
know what's at stake
in these uh speeches champion grand prix
events because
as i pull up the standings here of the
overall standings in the grand prix
parham axulu in first hike martial
roasting in second
he doesn't need to qualify he's the
reigning speeches championship
winner so he's already in artemyev he
would
likely get an invitation regardless but
then we see people like
kovalev and draken nvl will get an
invitation regardless i'm sure
oparin chigayev and karjakin your
karjakin may be
one of those players who would be
invited but you don't want to
risk it for invitations so let us
move on here because wonderful time is
at a perfect five out of five and i said
i wanted some more
min lei in my life and let's get his
game
up for you all and here he plays
a very solid start who is m boyan
boyan maximovic from bosnia and
herzegovina and
so let's see here
so we see a london setup
where these this pawn chain for
wonderful time safe and sound plays a4
just to
you know keep black on his toes there's
a threat of a5 at some moment and it
stops b5
so the knight came into e4 this knight
can just return
the favor by you go into e4 i'm going to
attack you on
e4 so let's this position's a little bit
dry for my taste so we'll come back here
in a bit uh just so such a solid london
position and rook a7 that's thematic to
bring the queen
to a8 to use the bishop on
b7 on that long diagonal so let's go to
this game here and we have
moussard with the white pieces against
dimitri colars
and oh i did i jinxed dimitri's opponent
earlier i felt like
i said dimitri was gonna yes that was
the rook and palmer's rook and pawn game
i was like i was pretty sure that i saw
a game of dimitris where
he a thousand percent was going to make
a draw and then
yeah let's not replay that let's not uh
go back in time for that one
so this pin is annoying and black can
consider playing g5 at some moment
but you have to watch out for any kind
of sacrifice on g5
there is the potential to give up this
knight to blast open this king on g8
so queen came to a4 other side of the
board i was just talking about g5
here comes the queen hitting this knight
on c6 if that knight were to move
then there would be some d4 possibly so
look at that move rook b5
puts an additional attacker on the a5
pawn but thankfully for white you have
two pieces
defending it so i think you can just
take and then maybe
swing this rook over to b8 use that open
file you can't
use it completely thanks to this knight
on c4 it's covering the b2 square
but that looks like it is an ambitious
tribe for black
so this position still remains solid
let's go to
abductor of his takes on zvyad azorya
what's going on here
it looks like a solid foundation for
black with the
pawn structure like this uh the
pawns are taking away forward squares
from white
and well not so fast i guess e5 played
anyway by abusive tarvin if you take and
take what's this looks bad
because you've opened up the position
and only
one side has a bishop and it is
black
so this is looking
like a better position for black
slightly
not too big of a deal just yet but this
is not what you want from the white side
of a sicilian where you
give your opponent the bishop and now
also the
c file
so yeah this is
just looking pleasant for black even
though it's not that
you know great like it takes takes
there's opportunities for white to start
trading off some pieces and
if you can't attack my ponzi 2 more
times
well then you're not really going to
benefit too much
so all right we're seeing some trades
here perhaps rook takes and rook to d2
maybe this one will just liquidate
let's keep on moving here within the uh
top bunch of games
jeffrey zhang is taking on lavon
ponculia
jeffrey with the black pieces looks to
me to be
slightly better for white thanks to this
pawn on e4 and
the bishop pair but i know this stems
from
an opening that is known often for
giving a sub i also don't like the look
of this diagonal this bishop needs to be
on g7
to make the king feel safer and h5 feels
like it just
invites right over to the king side i
would think about queen c1 and queen
over there and said f4 is played
trying to get oh actually that might
even be stronger e5 e6 and this pawn on
g6 is in trouble
that's that's not good you don't want to
see that
that looks very direct so h4
played by jeffrey g4 what
isn't that a a fork
oh ho ho jeffrey said i'm not just going
to sit back
and do nothing if you take me on e5
there's a check to your knight
in addition to check your king so you
are going to lose this piece in the
center
so that means after rook takes e5 king
h1
was the move and if you look at things
now there's no more discovered check
if you take my rook i take back with my
knight and it opens up my bishop
so i think that jeffrey was going for a
tactic
to help his position and as the sirens
go you know that the ambulance is coming
unfortunately jeffrey's position does
look at like it's beyond repair
at this point because this bishop is
still
very strong here still going to be
threats against the black king and
you've already lost them to 96
that looks great i was going to mention
how the e6 square you can't capture me
because of
the pawn on g6 but now it works even
better because now i'm forking your
queen and your rook
and the bishop opens up on this oh this
is just too much happening here
this is unfortunately for jeffrey just
game over
i i was just about to talk about 96 then
he plays queen c5
which walks into an additional fork
dang just take it now with your brook
and this pawn and this and this
you know everything here it's just a
mess and it's a mess is winning for
white
so jeffrey unfortunately for him he goes
down to lavon ponce
strong georgian grandmaster and let's
keep going
we still have plenty of games left
and this one between abusive torah and
zvyad zorya black is now up a pawn but
this king is getting
quite active over here so king c4
can be played to put pressure on this b4
pawn and you can even
i think you could have taken and played
king c4 and gone off this pawn that was
a
i believe a mistake because takes takes
king c4 you're just winning this b4 pawn
very directly so i would have gone for
that
and instead we have well now the rook
still
can be active not that it's just on the
board because the bishop is doing a
great job
of defending this pawn that was a missed
opportunity by
abdustoro
and
okay so azoria trying to
get this one i'm gonna keep on going
because he's a more aggressive type of
positions here
for moussar he is taking a dimitri
colors this looks bad for
white because this g-pawn is about to
become a queen
it's a pawn in name only this is about
to help that one
go free so where should the king go g7
that's a queen with check that's winning
that's completely winning for black you
are now up a
full queen and your king is actually
safe thanks
is this g-pawn gonna queen again is that
the plan
oh my gosh too many extra pieces so
it looks like azoria by the way and we
can let this one play out
uh for a checkmate because it's gonna be
checkmate in just like a move from now
queen b3 is checkmate there it is we
have zorya who is now
trying to win this but kinky two takes
rook g3 and this one
you lose both this is winning this is
winning hey
there's chess going on here you don't
gotta blare
your horns and sirens respect the chess
so yeah these pawns are just being
pushed
and your king can even try to come out
this way but here the king's coming to
g5 the rook can come to e3 with check
now rookie 3 is actually winning
and then f4 is a fork you take and the
king comes in
so king g3 king f2
and i think it's instructed just to see
it play out that's how you win this
position
is you get the opposition the white king
had to pick a side
and the black king went the other way
right so the white king
picked each one so the king comes in
picked f1 the king comes h2 and the pawn
promotes regardless so that's a nice
finish there
by azoria and by the way wonderful time
did win
the game against emboyon so that means
we'll have more wonderful time
in the future sounds adorable when i say
it out loud but
it's just true more min queen d8
queen e5 keep this pin on queen 85 check
keep the king in front of the pawns this
is a really smart defense
by no why would you make a draw
if you're white you have to play on here
there's no way you can just accept that
this is a draw
you need to somehow get your king out
it's not it's you know easier said than
done but you need to work for that
there's no reason just make a draw
but time travel makes people do things
that they regret
and speaking of time black loss on time
no kelvin kelvin
don't lose on time in this position just
move your knight away somewhere
oh poor kelvin sanchez but widdick
happy for sure so we have wonderful time
taking on lavon panzerlaya
let's see how this goes and well
min plays d4 in the first move as per
usual and
levon's connection here is just two bars
and that's not a good thing for him as
he takes on one of the fastest players
in the world
and once more we see that min plays c3
he's going to put his bishop up like e3
and play the solid london that's what
he's going for and because he's doing
that again i don't want to look at his
game
min you know i respect your chess
immensely
but come on give us something a little
more exciting in the london game after
game
let's go to sasha grisha as he takes on
gwenplan if i'm not saying that is boris
grucha let's check it out it is indeed
boris scratchup
and well i said i didn't want to see a
london system now i see
a london system but with the bishop on
c whoa okay all right boris
you getting frisky on the queen side
over here trying to go b5
and kick this knight and might play for
c4 so you play a3 you can play for c4
so perhaps it looks like you're playing
more aggressively than you really are
the idea is just to gain some space
first and then play for c4 so nothing
too major just yet and let's
continue on down the list because hikaru
is back towards the top
he has five out of six he takes on
pragnanda
and in this position for white he played
knight to d2 this rook is trying to come
to c1
and i think for black you probably want
to play rook to c8 you can drop your
queen back to b8 to
get out of any sort of discoveries
because rook a to c1 threatens bishop
takes up 7 check
so you just got to be careful about that
and
what should black do here
i would cons e5 ambitious move by
prognono the problem playing e5 and e4
is you've given up the d4 square
permanently and that's the issue anytime
you push
pawns they can't move back so the knight
got the e5 square
but the knight got the d-force course
it's a trade-off
of swords watch out for some kind of
knight to g4 that could be scary
at some moment probably doesn't quite
work out just yet but
something to keep an eye on queen to b8
bishop takes e5
this a7 pawn is hanging so will hiccaro
give up
his really strong bishop for a pawn
that's a trade-off that for many is hard
to do hikaru says hey
i'll take the material with my lead on
the clock i am the much higher rated
player
i'm you know the most experienced online
blitz player in the world
let me steal your pot and make you prove
that you have enough compensation for it
so what is black's idea going forward
put the rook on d8 all right i would try
for h5
just to expand on the king side white
lacks space
on that side of the board so black can
play h5 maybe even knight to g4 that
could be
quite a nuisance what else comes to mind
if i can trade off
these pieces here and get an opposite
color bishop's position maybe
that can help me make it draw but you're
just down the pawn
so that's not ideal i think cars play
this game very intelligently thus far
let's go back to wonderful time because
min his position is heating up i'm a fan
of it he can take on f6
and shatter levon pazzullah's pawn
structure
on the king's side but levon is making
the claim that
well only black will have a dark score
bishop and actually if i take
on f6 maybe i'll get e5 and later so min
puts his queen on f3 that puts immediate
pressure
on the f6 square and now knight e4
wait a second i'm not i can take you but
i know you'll just take me back
bishop b5 is what is about to say the
bishops
are taking away squares from that rook
and min is scooping
up the rook for his bishop that's good
a good thing how could it not be you're
winning material the potential downside
is not that what he's doing is bad but
that the
rook will not make itself felt in the
near future because
it's a very closed position the rooks
aren't doing
all that much just yet so queen h5
men use the opportunity to attack the
rook on eight that rook needs to move
somewhere
and now the knight can choose doesn't
want to go to f3 which it could not do
while the queen was on the square so you
can also play knight to g6
that is totally reasonable but i
anticipate if the knight comes to g6 the
queen will come to f7
pinning this knight so rook to a8 played
by panzerlaya just getting the rook
out of any harm's way and in came the
knights of g6 where
i would like to take you on f8 if i can
i can play f3 as well that's the good
thing when i'm putting my knight in f3 i
can push my pawn there
but queen f7 pins the knight not that
you can really pile of pressure on it
just a little bit of a nuisance maybe
bishop g3
i don't want to allow black bishop to
get to d6 so that's why i'm playing
bishop g3
so the position is a bit close for now
let's go back
to the game between hikaru and
pragma nanda not too much has changed
let me see
other games arjun air gazing on the top
board against what the heck is going on
dimitri
callers here it looks like there's a
king on c2 and that cannot be a good
thing
there is this pressure down the g file
so that's what arjun
is trying to rely on but
if you just trade the queens off the
board i don't think your king is really
in any danger
and white is down a pawn so that just
makes matters worse
now he's down two pawns temporarily he
can take
on h6 that's probably what
i would try as this pawn is pinned but
there must be a reason
oh my gosh is the rook get trapped if
rook h6 is g6 the move and kg7 traps the
rook
that's kind of sick i guess you have
rook h5 to escape
but i was trying to trap your rook in
there so e5 played
attacking the rook on a8
and black is still much better here so
i'm just going to keep an eye on
all these games here we also have exotic
princess that's bad or jabala
at five and a half to six taking on
maxine matlikall borsch
seven and while matlikov is
up in exchange and well this pawn on d4
can be annoying as pawn on b5
i just gave up the pawn on b5 to try to
chisel
at white's king side but i actually
don't think that that will amount to any
kind of advantage i feel like
white could even bring the queen to d5
try to push the pawn to b5
and this should be okay so i'm going to
juggle the remaining games really
quickly
hikaru reverse pragnanda pragma down to
his waning seconds here
he's defending well but he just doesn't
have the time to hold the position like
this e5 now
try to go e6 this is just a breakthrough
he takes on h4 also good but e6
is coming and you're not going to be
happy about the consequences
so hikaru up 30
plus seconds to 2.9 you cannot be in a
crazy tactical position and down
to just two seconds left so pragmata he
makes his move with half a second left
he loses a third pawn in the position
and hikaru can continue trading here if
he likes i wouldn't trade
just because of the clock situation i
feel like it's more complicated if the
bishop
has these pieces stay on the board he
does trade and i guess he's taking this
pawn here
a third pawn for him he doesn't
okay that may make his life more
difficult but the knight protects
everything protects the
checkmate and protects c4 queen e5 the
best you can do with no time
one point seconds left seven seconds off
excuse me probably not
really playing with no time and he's
doing it quite well honestly
but i feel like just two more moves then
it's over
okay wait queen d5 check queen d4 he's
picking up a little bit of time
so how can a car end this game a5 take
it
bring your bishop to b7 watch out for
queen e4 watch out
wait this is actually turning around
it's not checkmate because i can always
defend the mate
but still this is not what hikar wanted
this is not at all what he wanted
and now okay this is what he wanted the
queen just came off the board i didn't
even see that
queen to g2 happen and that's it once
the queens come off well there go the
pawns
so
here they go this bishop can't stop both
so you can play h6 even
or c6 first but the point is the bishop
is not in time
to stave off all the pawns bishop f5
c6 c7 and you can't
stop both good win there for a car
dimitri colors lost what
wait wait he lost on time
i mean the guy is just up a pawn here
well now he's not up a pawn he lost no
he still is of a pawn he lost some time
so levon pancholia wins dimitri
kolars loses so eric gacy moves on
surprising results there
towards the top
wow
okay so we see a knight and
three pawns against a rook and one pawn
this should be a hold for black white is
the one trying to win this game
because there's not really anything that
black can do to attack white sponsorship
be careful okay king of g6
there's no way to finesse it there's no
way to zoo swung it or anything
yeah the king's just going back and
forth and this king can do the same
so there we see a 100 move
draw so the point is split let's get to
anton korbov he has the white pieces
here bishop
oh this is a draw look at this wrong
color
bishop wrong color i'm gonna let you all
watch this play out i talk about this
all the time
i talk about this so frequently i'm
doing well
it's a draw by stalemate and the point
is you cannot
kick the king out of the corner so if
you ever played bishop d6 my king goes
back and forth and if you bring your
king up
and you go here you're just
allow me to stalemate and here there's
nothing you can do because my king
doesn't have access to these squares so
i got to let my king up so that was a
draw and a save there
well we have seven rounds in the books
that is
time for the second break this action is
really flying by
i'm having a great time we have two
leaders
co-leaders levon ponculia and arjun
irigase
followed closely by alireza farouja
bador jibawa
ziyadi zorya and then a whole host of
top players
at six out of seven so it looks like at
this point
eight and a half points will be the
magic number for qualification it
usually is with so many hundreds of
players in the field
but for now you'll have to remain on the
edge of your seats because
i'm taking a break when we turn we'll
get to round eight of the chest.com
speedchest championship grand prix stay
tuned everybody i'll be back
in a few
[Music]
so
and i'm back hopefully you did not miss
me too much because that would just be a
mistake
and we are getting ready for round eight
of the speeches championship grand prix
a lot in the line in these tournaments
because it's not just about the
qualification each individual tournament
has a
first place prize of 750 as you see here
places all the way to fourth and even
the best streamer and best female player
get prizes so it's great to see this
prize money for a couple hour blitz
tournament
and there will be a knockout the top
eight players will reach
a knockout so it looks like the action
is underway we do have lavon
panzulaya taking on arjun irigase arjun
fortunate
it feels like to be at seven out of
seven after that last game somehow
dimitri colors who is
such a quick player lost on time and
now what's going on with levon pounce
he's spending a heck of a lot of time on
move two
he makes his first move and now he spent
30 seconds
uh oh did he lose connection that would
be
a very sad way to lose your undefeated
record
is by dropping a game because his
connection seems okay based on the three
bars i have no idea
um i'm trying to figure this out right
now it seems like
he's just not moving so let's move on
well if he's not gonna move we might as
well
so let's go to ali raza faruja with the
white pieces
against uh badur jibawa
we see the queen come out to b3 where it
puts pressure both in the center and
on the queen side now the queen side
not really in that much danger thanks to
this great pawn structure it's not the
first time today
i've had the chance to talk about a
position like this where
black has such good control of the light
squares and
only white has a light square bishop so
you're hoping to have the
bishop pair the two bishops advantage
but it's not so much an advantage just
yet
thanks to this very compact pawn
structure for black
aiming towards d5 the triangle sticks
out in the center so white will play for
e4
that is the intention right now e4 makes
perfect sense especially with this pawn
on g5
under attack so i think that this would
be a good opportunity for alireza to
play for e4 now black can consider b5
this is thematic you play b5 not just to
offer some trades but even to play b4
to make e4 more difficult so i know it's
a bit hard to see in advance but i think
that was
one of the main ways to go whereas this
although you have taken a pawn for black
you've given white control of the center
and there are bishops and those bishops
will want to just break this position
open at some moment
and i could foresee this becoming a
problem
for black although bishop g5 not sure i
love that move though i get the point
here comes e5 here comes knight e4
maybe this queen will swing to e2 to get
out to this pawn on g4
alersa did it i should acknowledge that
it's probably a good move and i think
that
the more that i'm seeing the position
clear
there should be two hey what why is the
why is the bishop back to d2 i could
have sworn
that he was going for e5
right like e5 knight here knight e4
perhaps there's c5 and the whole
position collapses and that's why he
didn't do it
but that's what i was looking at once he
put his bishop on g5 so
here comes e5 here comes queen to e4
attacking this pawn on g4 directly and
that could be a problem for jibawa
because once i take on g4 i'm going to
h4 h5 i'm gonna hammer
right away at this pawn on g6 and there
could be
a blistering attack in the very near
future so
things will remain crazy here i'm going
to
check out on the top board game okay it
looks like ponzula
is back he's playing he spent a minute
three seconds
on move two i guess nobody told him he
didn't have to play with time odds in
this game
and he's in a very normal position but
has
what 40 seconds less than he should and
i wonder what was happening there still
the position is nice for white no real
risk just yet
you can play h3 to challenge this bishop
you can also consider
things like even a4 to try to play a5
and kick this knight away
and set d4 in the center right away okay
i can
i can support that this is attacked a
bunch of times and
these knights are awkward and this
bishop is not really staring
and doing anything it's turning to a
brick wall this way and this way wasn't
under attack
okay f4 i would have played f4
you're inviting me to attack your bishop
please take me here because now my
bishop aims
in both directions and threatens bishop
to c5
h3 bishop c8 play f4 okay he doesn't
want to push his pawn
which i can't fault him for thinking
that way and this pawn is
safe and sound in the center now he has
a knight here with his bishop
this is very powerful so what he did
ultimately been better than playing f4
because he didn't have to
create some problems for his own king a4
watch out
here comes bishop a3 winning
this exchange on f8 otherwise here comes
a5 and maybe even a6 just
breaking down this pawn chain that's
trying to stay here
on the queen side
so let's keep on going
as we look across the position what is
happening in ali raisa versus
uh badaward jabala it looks like black
is
up one pawn and queen d3 is trying to
trade the queens off before the king
gets in danger
and you can just take and then play
bishop e4 and win this pawn
so that i believe is what holly race is
about to do here
and then black will maybe even push this
pawn to a4
and claim that the outside pass pawn is
more valuable
than having a pond closer to
the center because if you look at
white's pond only one
pawn island they're all connected over
here and black has
two pawn islands well three if you count
this pawn but you're going to lose this
pawn in a second
so here comes bishop takes d3 and then
black will play c5
just to pry open the position to trade
some
remaining pawns and i think that this is
what jibawa needs to
claim in equal position
so so many games going on zorya versus
car we haven't been here what is
happening in this one
hikaru with the black pieces how many
extra pawns are black i see
two here but it's only one extra pawn i
guess
anyway this is d okay d2 didn't work yet
knight of 5 takes away the d6 square
so 94 stops the bomb rook e8 and if
f3 can you just take you can just take
and that way your pawn promotes so
hikaru is
pressing here he was at
six out of seven before this game he's
well on his way to
seven and eight except this king is
stuck in the corner
and that's really frustrating knight d6
so you
take d2
wait but then there's no there's this oh
my gosh
check i think you check there
i think you check and then you check and
i don't think the king can escape
maybe it could have i don't know but it
looked like it wasn't escaping because
this is just
winning for black and he won by
resignation but if we go back to that
moment really quickly here
i'm looking at d2 check because if i
took the rook you get a queen that's not
good
so check here check and if your king
ever comes here
my mmm i can't go 94 i wanted to go 94
but just king f5 so
and if i go knight f3 you have king of
five still and here you have king of six
the knight is overworked
defending the rook okay so i i thought
there was something there but
maybe i was too excited
so the car moves up to seven out of
eight we get back to levon pansoulia and
arjun irigase here and i liked the
position for white
earlier well he just won my resignation
because this rook on d
is hanging as is this queen on h6
black's piece is all out of sorts
so levon poncilla moves to a perfect
eight out of eight
farucha and jabala in immense time
trouble
two seconds to three oh
stealing the night and stealing the game
is aliresa faruja
because in the last couple moves this
rook pinned the bishop
this rook pinned the knight there's lots
of pins happening here
and unfortunately this rook is not
protected so you can't take
on d4 without losing that piece
it's really getting crazy down the
stretch here jasmine he
loses to daniel darda from belgium
and the belgian i am checkmates the
peruvian grandmaster
and jonah willa we have
how many pieces does white have for that
queen
the answer is way too many two rooks and
two bishops for a queen
you gotta be kidding me rook takes g3
rook h5 checkmate
i don't see position like that too often
with so many pieces for it
the queen hello everybody hello youtube
hello
twitch hellochess.com hey everybody good
to see you all
glad to see so many viewers across all
the platforms
always nice to see people supporting
chess
and these players drew i'm just waiting
for the uh
the next round honestly because now
we're getting into territory where
players
are not in contention for the top eight
spots
so um that's where my focus has to stay
is with the
players who are trying to get in the top
eight well that gives me
i guess a moment to remind everybody of
what the overall standings are like and
for some of these players who are
[Music]
towards the top today they want to
break through to the top of the overall
leader board where perham
maxulou currently is positioned in first
he's in
pole position hike marty rossian those
players not playing today
artemyev we haven't seen him uh kovalev
nope
but on draken's playing his car's
playing envio was playing but i haven't
seen him so maybe he lost the game early
and withdrew
so we'll see how this
ends up after today we'll see if there's
any
players jumping into the top ten
okay so this game should be
a draw but what should happen and what
does happen in blitz
two very different things and the reason
why
is there's no way for white to make
progress unless somehow
black allows the check and the king gets
into g6 even that
in most cases wouldn't be winning but
that's what you're trying to go for
so checking the king away they're
already a move 128
they want to get to move 5 billion
how do they match the players they play
10 games the 10 game
swiss you can see that right
there look down there
the format's there oh wait how did the
pawn get dropped i was talking to you
all
and then the sound of the pawn went away
oh gave a check
and the king had to go back because this
is a common idea
the rook gets the pawn from here and now
it's
two on none
and just maneuvering around a little bit
but you can
just go g6 at some point
also grandmaster vincent kymer is
playing guess the move
so you can go on chess.com and play
guess the move and i see you vincent
i see you shouldn't you be playing
your games and focusing on your tactics
and all that stuff but no you're playing
guess the move
welcome vincent
okay king h6 bring the king in
so the
thread is g7 checkmate or rook f8
checkmate both checkmates work
here it is and are we done with that
round
yes we are we're done with that we're
moving on to round nine
you know that game was only 160 moves
casual all right well the top board that
i'm seeing
is hikaru nakamura against
ali raza farouja so they will go at it
and these two taking on
each other now we've seen icaru play the
white side of this position against
magnus carlsen
many many many times in the magnus
carlson chess tour
and the knight comes to d2 you cannot
take on e5
too early because queen d4 will hit the
knight e5 and the pawn in f2
so
we'll see what happens
and
let's see bishop out to e3 he's training
off the dark square bishops
the bishop advantage isn't so important
here because
it's a closed position so knights tend
to be very good in close positions
and for those of you wondering because
i'm wondering myself it seems that lavon
panzulia
just disconnected before the game
started
and that is why uh he does not have a
game
in this round he's still in great shape
to qualify for the
top but unfortunately it did seem like
he was having some issues
with his connection we saw the bars were
going down so
um hopefully he writes that for the
final game and he left
live chess on his own so do not want to
flame the rumor mill
i'm just letting you know what i'm being
told has happened so he is
still in the tournament right now so
back to the chess
the pawn is on a5 here taking up space
and
maybe a6 is the future if you can soften
the c6 square
perhaps that will be useful for white
for now it doesn't look like you're
getting
another attacker on c6 so it might just
over extend your pawn
and create some problems it said f5
played
for black and now f4 there is an issue
on the e5 square there may be an issue
down the e
file so hikaru trying to pose immediate
problems
for ali rasa here this pawn e5 under
attack if you ever take you're left with
an isolated f pawn so here we see rook
to g8 and this bishop would like to come
to d5
next there's an attacking chance here
for farrugia so let's
keep on moving down the list we have
alexander grishoek so you should be very
happy to see sasha i know he has so many
fans
sasha is playing this position from the
black side
and what is going on here it looks like
white has so many pawns
but in fact the number pawns is even but
perhaps
because just one pawn island for white
you see the connected pawns all across
the board
and black is missing a c pawn somehow to
my eyes it just makes me feel like
white's position is better even if
the position is not
that way because it is very solid for
black you know there's no weaknesses in
the position he went knight to
d8 to open up the c file and reroute
this knight into e6 at some point don't
drop your pawn e5
that's a hanging piece so perhaps you
just play f6 this queen's going to slide
up to b3
or c4 right away okay and the knight
comes e6 d5 is very well defended
c5 can be played here for
white and the thing about c5 is you're
trying to get a pass pawn very quickly
the downside is you're giving up control
of the d5 square so perhaps black can
just
at some point push this point to d4 and
even bring this knight into d5
behind the pawn
so let's see how this one continues i'm
going to go over to argentina gacy
against
swimmer chess summer chess is often
doing well in these title tuesdays
so we'll see um how this game continues
here the bishop on f5
what does that do it stops the rook from
coming into the
g6 square and is looking at the d3 pawn
the d3 pump protected now by this bishop
which is on a useful diagonal but at
some moment i could see if this bishop
moves from d2 and knight a5 type of move
so really a position that is
an immense struggle black can play e4 to
open up an attack on this rook
on g3 but if you do play e4 you're just
giving me that pawn and
perhaps the position opening up a pawn
and a bishop
for a rook that seems like it's a pretty
reasonable trade for
white but now bishop e4 comes and once
that happens
you take you use the g6 square to your
advantage this is
seemingly a nice transition for white
because the pawn e5
is the most vulnerable looking pawn in
the position even though it's defended
it's one that can be
under pressure so knight h2 trying to
bring this knight to g4 or bring this
rook to
f3 with some pinning ideas but the 97
already defends the square
so i'm going to go back to the hikaru
game versus alireza
there's a lot of pressure down on the
g file holy cow what's going on here
and
well this is looking intense but you
have both rooks and the king defending
the square
and if you don't actually land a
checkmating
plan then whatever you accomplish the
vortex a4 did steal a pawn so can you
take on e5
that's i think you can and once you
steal that pawn
this bishop is just going to be worse
than this knight which will come to d4
and this this pawn c6 is hanging with
check this queen is hitting each other
rooks are hitting each other
wait so this queen can be captured but
rook takes e2
you can take on c6 check first is what
hikaru does
and he takes on here and after here
queen f3 is coming
at some moment with a mating idea
and this rook's under attack here we see
a transition into
b4 and that wins a piece
b4 just wins the game knight b5 might
actually be a checkmate at some point
but that
nice attacking the a6 pawn so hikaru
with a wonderful wonderful win here
and he goes to eight out of nine it
looks like he's in
great positioning to qualify for the top
eight but he will need to
probably win his last game depending on
how his tie breaks look
let us go to oh kovalev is playing i
kept saying that oh i haven't seen his
name he's not playing today
he just wasn't at the top rook takes a
three rook takes a3 that's a problem
now you win on a2 so anashuk is just
crashing through here and crushing take
on b3
thank you for your pieces i don't mind
if i do and now i'm going to check my eu
king on a1 is toast so kovalev
it looks like his run towards the
knockout
kind of over at this point let's go back
to grishok
well or shook his down a couple pawns
here so who is this
this is mikhail demidov from the moscow
wizards
of the russia wizards now i should say
and he has a very good position he does
it to be careful because this rook on b2
is powerful e3
is an idea oh so he let e3 happen
now you okay the problem is if you take
this one's
cover this okay so what's happening here
knight d3
rook b3 looks reasonable ah but this
pawn was hanging with check
nope everything is hanging here
how did he get out of this so now it's a
knight and four pawns against a rook in
one
white is much better here if not
objectively winning
but the king is now starting to attack
these pawns like sasha has done
everything right lately now attack keep
attacking these pawns
rook takes f3 knight h4 check do not
take that bomb but rook before knight d4
okay that's probably pretty smart check
king d5
now this is this is winning the 94
covers so king f2
only move that's slow that was there's a
slow move
so poor sasha here i think king f2
was his one last chance to try to hold
this position because after
king e7 you take and then king to e3 but
the king is too close this way
you'll give up the knight for the pawns
but if the knight were to move then you
get a position like this where
you have chances to win the game
so grand delicious at six and a half
playing as matt lacov
but matlikov wins with the black pieces
he moves a seven half and nine
he can win his last game and get to that
very necessary eight and a half point
threshold we have a draw between vulgar
rasulov and fidel corrales
so all these results are coming in down
the stretch here
we have frederick svaney with black he's
on upper rook against eddie marcella
should be just a win
for black pretty simply and in fact
there was a win so i'm just going to
wait for the last game here a reminder
to everybody
of what's at stake in this event
there is 750 dollar
first place prize the top eight move
into a knockout
and then they will be playing for that
money
so just to remind everybody of the prize
fund
as we get set for the tenth
and final round of the swiss
is frederick related to rasmus i am not
sure
i would guess the answer is yes but i am
just robert hess and i do not know
everyone in chess that is the end of my
poetry for the day
so let's uh go to the last game that is
remaining here
artem chernobe with the white pieces
spata german is up a night in the pond
so it should just be winning
just don't walk into any stalemates that
would not be good instead you went on
time
so we get it we have the final round we
will see some quick draws i am sure
as we see every single time we get the
speed of chamber grand prix hikaru
versus
well actually for a car doesn't make
sense to make a draw you don't know how
his tie breaks match up
against the others and there are many
people at seven and a half so because
there are so many people there we might
not actually see too many draws i'm
going to pull up
as many games as possible that way
i can keep an eye on when the results
happen
and levon ponculi he is back he has the
black pieces against alireza fergia
not the parent he wanted by the way we
have a draw between
bilodo and is that is that really like
senko
let me open that real quick that is
karil hey
you snuck up there so krill makes a
quick draw we do have
other games with eight players with
eight points we have hikaru playing the
white side
of a french and we've seen this from him
today where he quickly had bishop d3 and
f5
so because demidov has put us upon a5
you know that he wants to play bishop a6
this is very smart play
by hikaru is he didn't want to play
bishop to d3 and allow bishop a6 right
away
now with bishop a6 you can drop this
bishop back if you'd like
so he kind of waited to so he felt there
was the right moment
to bring the bishop out jesus smart play
by
demidop nonetheless as you see f5 not
possible g4 not possible just yet the
pawns are
taking away the forward opportunities
let me highlight the pawn so i'm moving
so quickly
the forward opportunities from white
nook c4 here comes b5 here comes b4
and on the other side of the board
hikaru will try to play king g2
h3 g4 and all this stuff to push his
pawns
forward what is going on in this game
between
anashuk and arakali uh
akh vladiani tried my best there
and this is a position where black
doesn't have the fiance bishop and this
bishop can
come into g7 the rook will come to g8
and i would just retreat my bishop
on the diagonal that seems like a very
smart play to
eliminate black's ability to castle
so bishop g7 rook g8 bishop c3 for
example
that looks like a better square than b2
just taking control of both diagonals
and if queen c7 you'll have to play g3
then black will castle queenside and
it's a
very complex battle so bishop f4
e5 played by black now
okay rookie one pinning this pawn here
but can black not just castle and bishop
g3 so there's
a problem on the e5 square but black can
start with rook to e8 what a weird
position this has been
stemming from a sicilian
this is one of those positions where
black has open squares
dark squares in front of the king but
not easy to get to them
and that's at least the hope and e4 is a
possibility for
black as well so h3 you're going to move
the knight back there it goes maybe this
knight can come to h5
well not now you don't want to go there
actually yes you do because g4 doesn't
work you can just take on d3
so i was worried about g4 but after here
takes queen takes g4
there's queen f4 barely
holding on because the pawn on g4 is
pinned so you actually have to really
see all that queen e6
was played instead just defending in a
much more calm way i think that's a good
move
so anushka has his hands full let's go
back to hikaru things have changed the
position has opened up he has been able
to
get his pawn to f5 you see that the h g
file is now open
there were trades on g4 and then and
then on f5 and the pawn kept
marching its way towards the f5 square
so this position is clearly
better for white but there may not be
enough material remaining to
play for so much of a win because
you're going to protect your pawn on f7
that's the key here
and white can consider playing knight to
g5 and queen to h7
trying to pile up on that pawn so that
is what i would fear
if i were demid over the black pieces
but said he continues to
bring his pieces around the bishop on d2
does well to defend this pawn
and after queen to h7 this king can drop
the queen can drop i would i don't know
i just feel like white is the one who's
continuing to push forward here to
press against black's setup
and it's passive but it may just work
out
so let's go back to ali raza faruga
against levon panzulaya
we see that there's a knight on d4 and i
want to play c3 but i know that i
dropped the pawn
this knight can also hop back to b5 it
is black's turn
i'm just trying to think what white is
threatening so f5 was played by panzulai
and if you take i guess this
knight takes because you need to protect
the pawn on e7 so knight takes his force
and the good news for white is there's
the rook staring down at this backward
pawn
which will never be a truly safe and
sounds
upon that will remain unhealthy for the
remainder of the game i play c3 i don't
like this bishop here
i want to keep that bishop out there he
does it the problem with c3 is at some
moment that pawn on b3 can become more
vulnerable
but this bishop can also go to c4 as
necessary and this pawn on a6 is
actually attacked twice
so you can even consider taking it right
now
knight came to d3 knight f4 knight to e6
a very direct plan
for farouja back to nakamura's game we
just want to make sure that we catch as
much of the action as possible knight to
h7
bishop under attack this bishop needs to
go somewhere but it can't go here
wait take and queen h7 you're going in
for the checkmate
but do you get there
because the king has to go back to e8 so
here queen h okay bishop a3 check
and the problem is if your queen goes
away too far
you're giving up some control over the
b-file and that's
what black is really hoping for us the
king came to c1 first i liked that
that was really smart by hikaru but
that's another smart move keeping the
queen stuck to c3
so both of these guys are really playing
some great chess thus far showing you
how to improve or how to stay put
because
it looks like hikaru did well to get his
king up to c2 for example now there's
nothing happening on the
queen side so the queen is free to run
away but look at demi dog bringing the
knight to b5 attacking two pieces
so demidov not going down in this game
without a huge fight
quinny is sick there is a3 and now a3
here knight c6 take this bishop off the
board it's what you want
it's what you need honestly so i think
demidov really has worked his way out of
this game
hikaru has far more time but the
position is so
locked up here and what i would do is i
would take this
for sure on b4 and i can't play c3 right
now because the queen was hanging but
i'm considering playing c3 at some
moment
although why would i do that now that
the d4 pawn is weak
so knight c6 honestly a car might be
playing for a loss more so than he's
playing for a win take on d4
no no no no no this king is has to be in
trouble knight b5
uh oh that is painful
i really think this is going south
foreign
and okay queen takes i was pinning
okay so actually they drew
because this knight was pinned here and
he could have like i just chose really
quickly
because i think there was some
opportunity to like get the queen e2
and then push the pawn to c3 because
you're nice protected but black had no
time on his clock so i get it
so we'll move on ali raza fruga won his
game this game concluded in a draw
that is fortunate for hikara at that
point and we have anushka taking on
uh iraqi here this is a win for white
and the reason why is you play
f6 check and either the rook needs to be
distracted off the c file
or the king has to be distracted at the
last rank here f6 check is completely
winning
if you take this rook f8 if king of sun
is rook h8
you win the rook back once uh
black took so it looks like anashuk gets
through and is in
first place he is in the top position
and how many more people do we have here
we have okay
karacho with the black pieces taking on
bharara jabala jabal needs to somehow
fend off
gretchen's pawns he's not going to be
able to do that and even still the best
that
jabal can do from an objective point of
view is a draw and
not when you get down to one second left
that looks like you're just going to
lose
in a move here and he lost some time so
grouchev makes it through i will look at
the standings
you won't you won't know the final
standings until all the games are done
so where people are in tie break order
it may change with the final game so
this is the no these games are all
irrelevant at this point so we'll just
watch oh no we're not gonna watch this
queen versus queen
i will watch this one instead because
this is far more interesting
oh oh that's checkmate
this looks so interesting
like this was a rook and three pounds as
a queen and that king his check made it
oh that's painful
you don't see checkmates like that very
often that's like a
smothered checkmate all the way at the
board here
wow oh my gosh that is
a rare sight so we have just a few more
games left they don't impact the
standings so let me look at those things
let me actually take a
peek there so anashuk in first we have
bilo do
that is carrillo alexienko we have
gwenplan that is
boris grachev we have hikaru i don't
think you need to
find out who hikaru is you have demidov
kuzabov for ruja arjun iregasi and then
there's praveen balakrishnan pravin b
and i am there with eight and a half out
of ten but it looks like he's going to
be on the outside looking in
unless when the final standings
are locked in he could be the one
who sneaks in if some result happened oh
he is
if the tournament is over which it looks
like it is
praveen snuck in to eighth place
and arjun aragasi on tie breaks
is left out so arjun
what a sad state of affairs for him
he was playing really well today and
praveen balakrishnan
the international master the lone i am
taking on gm's
well he's going to try to send them home
in the knockout portion that will
be coming up after this break so i am
going to take a break
we will make sure the players are set
for the knockout portion
of things coming up whoo oh my gosh
really what 10 rounds this was
and we have hikaru we have farouza
we have alexenko we have onishok we have
groucho
i should stop saying the names go on
break we'll be back shortly the top
eight will play in elimination
knockout bracket stay tuned everybody
for more of the chess.com
speed chess championship grand prix
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
okay i am back and ready for the
knockout portion of things here i have
pravin balakrishnan on screen
he is the international master who
placed eight overall
in the tournament and what you may also
notice on screen
is an eval bar it is anathema to me i am
not happy about it
but i am doing it and i'm doing it for
the people i still cannot see
the moves that are suggested but i am
putting on the evaluation bar
because when all is said and done i
guess to some extent i am a man of the
people
so you're welcome and let me just
make sure i follow all of these players
real quick so that
i don't miss out on what's about to
happen
as the game should start any moment now
why do some of these players have such
long usernames
why'd they do that to me i gotta type a
lot i just did everybody a favor and
they're doing me no favors
but i'm ready for the action to begin
when it does and hikaru versus alexenko
that's an awesome pairing
so we have some great matchups
that are about to unfold we have
koozabov against farouja
and that is a really good one for those
of you who may not know
uh yuri he's a really strong ukrainian
grandmaster fruga is the higher rated
player
but you know when you have one game to
prove it
not always very easy so i think i am
following all the players now i'm ready
for the
knockout to begin so let us see that
happen i'm here for it game should start
any moment now sorry about that
i was uh just making sure everything's
in order we have the evaluation bar you
know it pains me
but here we go we have vladimir anashuk
taking on
praveen bella christian we have a karo
khan it is a glorified french in the
early stages there are four games going
on at once
i may not be able to switch the cameras
of the players while switching the
boards and all that so bear with me
but we are getting into the knockout
we're in the quarterfinals
so this pawn chain great for white this
we've talked about this so many times
today about the white
light square bishop is controlled by
these pawns because there's no
good diagonal for it just yet the knight
comes to f4 uh it
hits his bishop on g6 you can go ahead
and take that black isn't
too unhappy of by that so
let me make sure that everything's good
great
cool let's move on to for now just to
another game
actually no we're not because h5 is a
threat and i have experience in this
line
i played this position as the white side
against evgeny postney
as well as igor hankin and actually is
one of my
better wins not to flex or anything but
i i won a game in this
position from the white side so it's a
pretty cool line we're trying to play h5
and maybe even h6 so that's the idea
black is trying to figure out how to
stop that idea and you can actually play
knight bd7 but you have to know that
as the bishop gets to c2 bishop f5 i
don't like that move
you have to realize that the bishop has
an escape score on c2
for the time being and it can't be
attacked so easily so bishop f5
the problem is you have these double
pawns you cannot play g6 because the
open h file
is doomed for black right g6
what you want to do but after takes
takes knight takes g6 thank you your
rook is undefended back here
so unfortunately for praveen he's in a
tough spot right now
he is with the double pawns his opponent
has the bishop pair and this pawn f5 is
under attack but i like that he castled
and will try to bring his rook to e8 so
let's move on for now let's actually
move on to a different game
we have hikaru taking on alexenko while
these players
are this could be a game for the world
championship could have not
so let me uh bring up alexenko on camera
well we don't really have much
gone from except for his head now there
he goes there he looks up as soon as i
said that
and what's going on here that hikaru is
getting adventurous
with the queen maybe there's some kind
of queen a1 but not really the king goes
into d2
so it's all good here and
if the players draw they have to play a
bullet game
so that's what happened so
the king is can always skip to d2 so
alexenko if he's worried he can play
queen to c4 to trade off
the queens and i would be somewhat
concerned about an eventual knight takes
e5 opening up the d
file because i can imagine something
like this being
favorable for black so queen c4 there he
plays it alexenko just saying i'm going
to keep
a slightly better position and after
queen takes knight x you would like to
play king e7 to take away d6 but in
comes bishop b4 check
so here at knight a5 this is typically a
move that
really flusters black and the bishop
came to d2 first but knight a5 i think
to start with would have been better
because now look what black has done got
the first pawn to b5 the second
pawn will go to c5 shortly after rook to
c8
so that's something that um i think
alexander would like to take back his
knight here keeps the pawns
frozen so getting to the live position
here comes the rook to e1 black has this
knight on d5 that you cannot kick out
the c4 square is under
icarus control it looks like a very
level game
right now and will alexenko go forward
with a move like g4
no he puts the bishop on b4 please
please please take me on b4
because if you do you open up the a file
and there's a backwards pawn on a7
not to mention you will never get c5 in
if uh this pawn's on b4
we have a draw between karachev and
demidov i'm just going to pull that game
up real quick
the draw was agreed it's kind of
surprising how early that one was drawn
but let's come back here
and let's move on quickly to the game
between kuzabov
and ferruja because
while we're looking from these games let
me grab
ah where's his camera where are you
kuzubo i don't see you
well i don't see either of these players
so we're going to bring
the uh alexander back on
screen here and this position is looking
pretty solid for white
with the bishop on
d4 and this is like super well defended
here
white has slightly more space but this
pawn on a2 is under attack so i think
that ali raisa
all things considered it is fine let's
go back to the car versus uh alexis
actually no
no let's go back to praveen's game
because what is happening here
i'm trying to uh do eight things at the
same time and
you know things are
tough but speaking of tough isn't there
like a pretty big
threat down the h-file here like that
looks really scary to me and you saw the
eval bar just drop a little bit
as it first liked white's position even
more than it does now because
there's actually quite a serious threat
and the threat is if you take it looks
like you're forking the pieces
i can check you and i can go queen h1
and once we trade queens here
my rook wins yours on a1 so
why this compensation but i don't
believe anything more than that if this
were to occur
and rook b1 knight takes a4 pravin
the international master he's saying
don't underestimate me
i will still have threats of a check and
going down to h1 trading all the pieces
off
because the b2 pawn is one that needs an
eye kept on it so instead
we see a trade on c5 even material
blacks pieces lined up well the eval bar
is dropping
in pravin's favor and what can you do
here many different options
i would say bringing this knight into e5
is one of them he said brings his queen
in first
to h3 and now the position
i see the bar it's going in white's
favorite a little bit that means that a
queen trade
will be favorable for white so black has
the knight and bishop against
two powerful bishops that's the idea
and rook d1 hitting this bishop directly
on d6
that's not something that you're
very happy about and these trades
certainly not something you're happy
about we're getting into
an end game with a bishop pair and even
g4 here the bishop
spies the g6 pawn through the f5 pawn so
g4 will just break the position open
at some moment here rook to d6 watch out
there are two pieces in a row
he starts with bishop to b3 the knight
is escaping
king f4 there's knight h3 check if i can
draw my error as well it forces the q
what okay that makes some sense okay
he's going after the b7 pawn but
going into an opposite color bishop
position
could not have been me honestly well now
it's just looking overwhelming rook to
d8
giving up the b7 pawn probably was
better than this because now c5 c6 is
just a mating threat
with the king stuck on the corner yeah
c6
maybe was a practical choice when all
said and done
b6 threatening take here with mate and
you can't take on c6 but b6 just wins
the game
and 19 seconds on the ship's clock
counting down he plays b6
so unfortunately for praveen this one is
not looking like it's going his way
not at all this pawn is gone
and check and c7 and actually
regulate check to be fancy rookie eight
oh
rookie at first was checkmate on the
spot
by the way hikaru did win this game
against alexandro and kuzabov
beats farouza and the maid i was talking
about was here rook
8 king takes c7 that is check and mate
that would have been the end of things
but what
anushka did was good enough so we do
have
one game heading one match i should say
heading to thai breaks that is
grochev and demidov we'll take praveen
off the screen he doesn't need to
be shown anymore let us get demidov
as he's hanging out he's getting ready
for
his bullet game that's what's about to
happen is bullet
between grochev and demidov
here we go let me flip the board around
and
no the position is not plus uh 20 or
whatever this is saying let me refresh
my page just clearly
catching on to the last game and here we
go okay why is it
i'm only following one of these guys let
me follow grouchoff as well
but you see the position out of the
gates here
it is a king's indian looking position
but white has not put upon e4 so it has
this uh
king's indian type of plan where you're
pushing forward and white is trying to
claim space in the center here's c5 that
opens up the c4 square for bishop
this is a pure bullet game there is no
increment the winner moves on otherwise
we get more bullet if it's a draw
so g4 played gaining more space f4 hangs
the g4 pawn
and you don't really want to play knight
f6 and give up this pawn anyway so g3
if you take with the bishop there was f4
as we took with the f pawn looks ugly
for now it is an extra pawn
black giving away pieces saying here
take a couple pawns but
give me the e5 square let me open up the
a file for my rook
the c5 pawn can be captured with check
now from a practical point of view i
like what black is doing but i'm worried
that it's too many pawns
queen d6 great move trading off the
queens so that you can
go ahead and keep your extra material
and not have to worry about your king
safety
so what can black do now bring the next
knight into e5 you know that's
that's reasonable bishop d4 if the king
goes to h1 knight comes to e5 perhaps
there's some pressure
down the h file instead we'll see rook
takes f4 and bishop e6
that way we can recapture on f8 and go
for the f-file
so bishop d7 that seems too passive
for my taste and 20 seconds for white
just under 16 now for black bishop g4
played offering exchange piece oh
blundering a piece in the center
so now it's just going to come down to
the clock white is winning objectively
but if demidoc could be the faster
bullet player he has a chance here
i don't think he will be rook to b4 okay
good but look at the time situation
white still
several seconds ahead knight g4 hits the
bishop this pawn c6 and recapture and if
you take on c6 there's rook to g6 to
follow
so g3 plays setting up a mating net
that's what he's going for he was trying
to set up a mating net
here comes the king back to h6 the king
wants to get out of here black down to
four
seconds but moving quickly now take on
g3 blood under the rook
try to pre-move didn't work out and
demi-dove is unfortunate for him we have
him on screen looks like he
is the one who is losing this game yes
he has lost some fortune for him that is
boris grouchov with the speed and the
strength
and he does go on to win this game
and well we'll let demi dove get off
camera for a second let's remind
everybody of what they're playing for
now that
the final four the semis is set
we have these four players playing for
these cash prizes
they want to earn their money here
unfortunately for demi dog we had him on
camera he has to
sit it out but that's what's uh
happening grechov
sitting in the dark by the way and he is
uh
the winner so with that we're going to a
quick break
we are going to set everybody up for the
semi finals
you see on the left hand side of your
screen here
vladimir honorship wins against praveen
balakrishnan yuri kuzubov with the
upset by beating alireza frugia we have
boris gracia taking down demi-dolphin
bullet
and finally last but certainly not least
we have ikar nakamura
moving on to the semis and he will face
boris grouchoff we'll be back in a few
minutes now
stay tuned for more action from the
speeches championship
grand prix brought to you by chess.com
[Music]
so
and i return here ready for the
semi-finals
of the speaker's championship grand prix
we have uh
vladimir understood on camera well we
kind of have him on camera he's sort of
sinking lower and lower it feels like
a lot of space above his head feels like
we just stepped out of austin powers
with that wallpaper i'm here for it
though
and i hope you're all here for some
exciting chess because we are about to
get into the two matches the two
semi-final matches
and then the winners will face off for
that 750 prize
so i am excited for the all ukraine
battle
between vladimir anashuk and yuri
kuzubov
and then we have hikara nakamura taking
on boris graceff
so it should be a fun one and
i don't know who's the favorite between
anushka and kuzba i'm going to go with
anishuk
slight favorite but maybe i may i just
don't
know koozaba's blitz strength the same
way i
do know on the shoes so oh we have
liftoff
right now so cruz about gets the white
pieces in the first game
honestly is slightly higher rated
between the two players
and we see d6 on move one which is
playing for a modern defense kind of a
slower approach
and here we have c4 so king's indian now
achieved
and e5 so here we has many options the
point of d5 is you lock up the center
for now and
white will play for c5 that's the idea
is that you want to push this pawn to c5
and he plays it right away because the
pawn e5 can be captured if this pawn
wants c5 were captured so we see a trade
immediately and a4 plane that's an odd
looking move to me because this b4
square
is now under black's control not that
that's
too big of a deal just yet i don't
really like the look of it and this
knight is coming into c4 to put pressure
on d6
that's why the rook came to see it first
and what's the knight doing on b3
i'm not sure i understand white's plan
exactly
maybe knight to b5 because if you take
with the bishop i take with the pawn
but anashuk is
he's trying to figure this out himself
right now
from the black side and that wallpaper
is really cool i know i
sound like i was making fun of it and
like that foxy cleopatra would jump out
of nowhere
but i really i'm digging it honestly i
think it's cool
i don't know where he got it and f5 for
black is always an option but is white
attacking this pawn a7 you have to
calculate because you want to play b6
afterwards but then white would be in
time play a5 to extricate the
bishop from the a7 square
and let's see rook to a8
passive for now didn't want to play b6
then a5 would have been a possibility
just trying to pry open the position and
now for
white it plays knight to b5 so here b6
makes sense you can't play a5
that knight on b5 needs the defense of
the pawn on a4
and as we can see the evaluation bar you
know how much it pains me
to reference it but as we see it here
that it is about
level and white is slightly slightly
better thanks to having a bit more space
but i do think
that black's position is easier to play
because if i ask you what is white's
idea you're like um
well well look these are knight to c3
but isn't black's idea with f5
more clear cut that's just a move that
gains space my knight can then go to f6
behind the pawn rather in front of it
and then i'm taking over
squares in the center of the board so b5
play keeping the position closed the
pawn on a7 is defended by this rook on
a8
that's good news for black the pawn b5
future
potential target and you don't have
knight c5 ideas because white has two
attackers
and black had two pawns defending but
now only has this one pawn defending
here
so queen v8 that's a really nice move
trying to go for b4
so you can play bishop b5 in the future
b4
uh yeah before it does hang this knight
for the time being so you have to
keep an eye out on that but perhaps it's
possible because b4 queen a6 bc3 rook c3
thank you
thank you for your queen it's trapped
over here so that is not a good look
for uh for white in that line
so as a refresh get to the current
position h3 played
i'm still looking for f4 type of ideas
i'm still looking for b4 i can play
queen b7 and kind of slow play it
with b4 but this is a position that i
believe
is getting more and more favorable for
any shook here
so let me we'll have a moment i can
bring in
wait where's koosabo where are you
i don't see you on camera is he
streaming is that why
is yuri kuzabov streaming let me ask
if he is that would explain why i can't
get access to uh
his camera ah he is streaming
the more the more you know
they say the less i know the better if
you're a tame impala fan but
honestly would have been good for me to
know that so knight comes back to a2
where attacks the b4 pawn a second time
but there are two pieces
defending that uh pawn the knight and
the queen for black so
kind of awkward knight on a6 just
is doing his job it's defending so i
brought the queen to b7
just to start putting pressure on the d5
pawn if i play queen b7 perhaps i'll
follow up with eventually with e4
shutting your bishop off on g2 so that's
really
one of the main ideas here for black is
to try to get after this d5 pawn
which is has wandered a little bit too
far
and the knight on a2 the knight on b3
they're not doing anything these knights
are just
controlled totally controlled by black's
pieces
so why is anastro spending so much time
here
okay he makes his knight jump into e4
it's also a good move
if the bishop takes an e4 you take out
the f pawn and his pawn h3 becomes a
target
and it's pawn d5 also remains weak
wait but this pawn on b4 is hanging i
understand the queen's under attack
first
but you can consider taking and then
taking this pawn on
b4 so this is why and this is what
kuzubov is doing here he steals that
knight in the center
he can take this pawn he does so and
black's position is on the verge of
collapsing
you notice how one little inaccuracy can
do your position in here
and 94 i think was a fine first one we
saw the evaluation bar
totally content with that move but after
rook takes i think you had to take with
the bishop because you need the queen
to stay defending this pawn on b4 and as
we get to the live board
now that you've lost the pawn you can
take on h3 good for you but d6 e4
all these pawns are in trouble so now
rook to b that's a very good move it
keeps the queen
tied down to the knight on b3 the queen
drops back to a3
fair enough and if bishop takes h3
bishop takes a7 the bishop can park on
b6
so queen e6 i like this move as well
honest he is in some trouble here
and he's down on the clock but at least
he's creating counterplay the pawn on e2
queen of c4 would hit this knight on b3
hit the spawn on d5 and actually
maybe even bishop takes h3 stole the
pawn so it started to look a bit iffy
but in just a few moves anushka has been
able to
restore material quality fix the
location of his pieces
and make sure that his pawns are just
not collapsing
so here the knight came to c4 this pawn
on d6 is already defended is a rook to
b7 maybe rook to b5 go after this d5
pawn
but clear that he wants to move his
queen away a6 very tempting it's a
committal move it puts your pawn in the
a6 square
for the rest of the game but it does
cement this pawn on a7
whoa okay that move caught me off guard
for sure queen takes e6
it's a free piece honestly was able to
steal the piece from his compatriot
and unfortunately for kucibov that was
just a massive blunder
like truly uh a surprising mistake
and now the a6 pawn is done
and black is up a bishop and a pawn here
this is just an easy conversion for
undershirt
what a turnaround what a turnaround
so that's game one in honestruk's favor
and he gets the white pieces in game two
and all he needs is a draw
that's it
so now we have ownership with the white
pieces he's probably going to try to
just remain
calm and you know keep his composure not
do anything
too risky and look at this position you
know playing for a win from this
position for black
typically is not so easy however we have
seen this
played at the highest level for quite
some time now
where honestly this move h5 hard for
newer players to ever even consider
because their coaches tell them do not
push pawns in front of your king
but in some of the main lines black does
play h5
really to stop white before the pawns
can push this is a different line so
it's not necessary
and i think that honestly has done the
right thing by trading pieces he only
needs a draw
he has the superior pawn structure as
his pawns are not doubled like
blacks are these f7 f6 mods
so this is just a
nice looking position for white nothing
that is weak no hanging pieces
no vulnerable squares even so that's
what black is going to try to do is
quickly create a weakness here or there
to
try to push forward because otherwise
how can white complain about this
position
trying to trade rooks off i don't think
this was the right
opening for kuzubov in a must-win
situation
so now you can just trade the queens off
keep trading
if you're honest look at the evaluation
bar slightly better for white
you might see that in the point three
point four here it says complete zeros
but i don't really see white getting in
any
risky situation b5 was a good move
because now the knight's trying to get
to d3
and that can be an annoyance so the
bishop can slide all the way home to f1
that way you keep the d3 square under
your control
and after bishop f1 you may play rook to
c1 and pawn to c4
just make sure that black gets nothing
whatsoever there's literally nothing
that black is getting out of here
so all right so we see a trade on
e1 if you play a3 i could see a future
where your pawns get stuck and then
black will try to bring the knight
around like knight d5 knight b6 knight
a4
that's something that i would look at
but in the meantime this knight is
coming in
to c5 via e4 so f5
is a good move taking away this very
important square from the knight and
there it is played
so cruz about he's stopping white's plan
and then
eventually he will try to create one of
his own that could be a5b4
to break open the queen side just to get
some sort of play you're playing
where you're pawn down but at least you
can open up some lines for your pieces
okay maybe h4 coming
g5 can also be considered
and now g5 is possible
knight d5 check is also possible and you
will need to protect your pawn here so
h4 is the move that i would be tempted
to play
because i'm trying to remove the guard
of your knight on f4 right if i play h4
and you take me yes you're attacking my
knight but i'm going to take yours and
look at the pawn structure at the end of
this
well i don't think you're very happy
about these
island in the position so h4
was indeed played that was the choice
and you could play f6 probably the
right choice by who's about to keep the
position closed and said knight to g6
you cannot take a pawn it's not free
as f4 would have happened now the king
came back so that if you take on h4 i
take on h5
so it is a trade of pawns
and knight takes h5 it's probably a good
trade for white because now your knight
is more active here
and your bishop can just run out to d3
and the knight was on f4 before which
was a pain
now that it's an h4 but it's not really
doing anything
so bishop d3 is a
free square now the knight isn't
taking advantage of it okay king e7 this
rook
can come to h8 but then the knight can
even come to g7 to take this bishop
on e6 if necessary so bishop d3
rook to h8 could even consider g4 there
just need to think about that a little
more actually g4 was a blender let me
show that really quickly
here rookie g4 knight takes f3 thank you
if you take i take on g4 and i win your
knight
because it's check and i take your
knight next so knight g7
team d6 we see a trade and bishop takes
c4 this pawn is weak here comes rook to
e5 and
swing that rook over that's what i'm
looking at
okay swings to h1 also good there's also
the h7 square so the rook for white is
more active
whereas black's rook is being used as
defender white also has an additional
30 plus seconds here and so i don't
know how black intense like create a
breakthrough
push through in any way here you know
rook 8 a5 that's one way to try but then
this rook comes to h6 and
r to e1 and hits the pawn on
e6 so rook h6 makes sense
then knight to d5 is forced and i do not
want to trade that's
something white certainly does not want
to do is trade on d5 called the king up
and the king attacked the pawn no no no
no
that's not what this is about
but anashuk is smartly thinking here he
has
plenty of time he's up now 15 seconds
counting down to 10
but he doesn't want to rush this because
as soon as black plays a5 there's
suddenly counter play
whereas black was sitting and doing
nothing before now a5
opens up the position for this rook on
eight and he's thinking a little
too long in my opinion
it's actually concerning me for his
chances
rook h6 was played in rook h7
so is a5 the move or a5 there's b5 oh
that's actually sneaky b5 if you take
bishop takes rook d7 is a checkmate
threat
get 97 though don't get checkmated do
not blunder this checkmate
i've cursed people enough today see it
don't blunder it you see it i know you
see it yuri
he is okay he played rook to d8 so he
saw it rook a7
attacking a5 and black can play f4 and
try to get this knight into e3 that's
one of those ideas where instead of just
sitting and protecting your pawns you
give up a pawn for activity
so knight c7 take this pawn a5
and with this simplification it makes
the drawing chances much higher
and if that's the case then one stroke
will be very happy
so good idea there's some kind of
discovery somewhere
but it doesn't actually do anything the
king just moved back
so you're not scared of that bishop f1
king d6 okay
so rook h3 to attack the spawn
this knight in c7 is really restricting
white's pieces so rook h2 you need to
attack something though
okay that's a good start here is this
pawns under that with g4 this rook takes
g5
take on g5 liquidate
trade off the pieces and that's what
punisher was able to do just now
bishop d3 and then there's knight d5
stuff so king d3 was more precise
and now take on g4 and now white
probably would actually just win this
game and
a draw and a loss for the same match
result for kuzabov
so you know what's the point of making a
draw if it
costs you the match you might as well
lose the game
and here comes the g pawn objectively i
don't think this position is lost yet
but i just think that he will lose the
game based on the match situation
i don't think he cares so much about his
you know four rating points or whatever
on chess.com so king d6
g6 good and this knight is
dominated by this bishop
that's the problem and if 98 this bishop
b5 or bishop takes
e6 so they can't even go to e8 two
seconds one second
barely got to move off white can just
move the king back and forth
you can play for a win with king e5 why
not oh king of six and you win
rook one of these squares and you take
it
and you take it and you promote
i told you white was gonna win this game
nothing really to be done so anashuk
wins the match two to nothing he take i
like his
his mug too is that a heart on his mug
he's fashionable
that's what we just saw so he's gone he
he left us but he is moving on to the
final where he will
face the winner of hikaru nakamura and
boris
gracia so i'm going to bring boris on
camera hikaru is streaming
his games so i don't have immediate
access i can pull up his channel
and watch from that way but that just
adds
complications to my life and i will
bring up boris
here he is he's in the dark he's ready
for his game it looks like
we're ready to go to sleep i'm not sure
which one but
either way he has a match to play and
no slouch in the car nakamura that's for
sure
so probably going to start in just
a minute or two it's waiting for a
word from the team behind the scenes
as we have the second semi-final about
to take place
and no liftoff yet i think they're just
talking to the players it seemed like
boris was reacting to something
so he's running a hoodie he's
he's ready to go
and we
wait for the next game to take place on
a blank board
and here we go we have liftoff a car not
more gets the white pieces
in the first game and boris starts with
the sicilian
and well
knight out to c6 you're challenging the
center right away we could see the move
g3 it's a very popular move here
uh there are a number of good plays
at this point for white and he takes on
c6 and plays bishop d3 so this allows
black to expand
with d5 and the good news for black is
you have a very strong center
here the bad news is you never want to
take on e4 because if you take on e4 you
get isolated queen pawns
a queen set bones excuse me and that's
an issue so that's why
white keeps this tension and sometimes
even plays knight a4 and pawn c4
saying you really do not want to capture
with this pawn as you're left with once
queen b6 walks into knight a4
and c4 is just an idea that i was
mentioning so i don't like that move
by groucho
boris is a very good player
unfortunately for him
if he wanted an easy match he wasn't
going to get one not in the speeches
championship grand prix semis
no sir and here's c4 and the point of c4
isn't to just
win a pawn because this pawn d5 is still
well protected but here comes a rook to
c1
trying to take over the c file
in bishop a6 you're actually not really
threatening anything because you still
do not want to take on c4 it's really
frustrating
to have this kind of position the bishop
also stares at the king side so watch
out
for potential sacrifices let's say rook
c1
bishop a6 some kind of rook c3 type of
maneuver
where you can take on h7 swing this rook
to the king side
and look for a mating attack i know i'm
speaking a lot but a lot of things that
do not seem like they will take place
but you should always be on the lookout
for such
tactics even if it doesn't seem
realistic you want to have the idea in
mind because you never know
when the right time will come or when
your opponent will make a blunder
so here rook to c8 you can also just
play much more
calmly and naturally rook c2 was played
i think the rook c3 was asking for too
much this knight could have always come
back to f8 and here we see a capture
what i don't like isolated pawns weak
light squares
that hikara can try to take advantage of
but for now still pretty solid for black
there's no checkmating initiative
nothing of that sort
queen of b7 swing that queen in line
with the bishop
and things could start to turn around
not that black
will be better that's not what i'm
trying to get at but just that it feels
like the game
is progressing more naturally for black
whereas for what you already have to
deal with this
idea with bishop takes g2
so we'll see so f4 played
and maybe knight to b6 offer
an exchange of knights uranus on d7 not
really doing anything
and it's not an a4 is a bit annoying so
well done by groucho if knight c3 of c4
just to trade off your isolated pawn and
open up a new diagonal for the bishop
so knight takes b6 queen takes b6 do not
blunder
c4 that's why i put the bishop on z4
black was trying to open things up but
here a4 speaking of opening things up
play a4 to open up the a file for rookie
okay actually the d5 pawn would have
been hanging on d5 instead
he plays this way but i think a4 is the
move
i think you just want to play this move
to
open up the queen side instead
he trades everything perhaps thinking
this this will be an
easy hold for him and objectively the
position
should be okay for black but practically
speaking you have this pawn on
um
on a5 that is a problem so that's
on a dark square and there's a dark soul
bishop for both sides
so looking pretty
pretty good here for white just a better
position no risk
at all black has these pawns that need
to continuously be defended here
and here goes the sirens
they're here for the pawn structure
i'm doing well though thanks for asking
everybody thanks for making sure that
i'd be okay
but queen of d1 that's a move i would
consider but i know that i'm giving up
the a5 pawn so that's something that you
have to be really careful about
so h4 played and
well what now
okay queen e4 queen d1 now makes much
more sense to me
but there's still this capture here
so g6 making sure there's no f5 and the
queen they can't give an e2
so the queen on d8
doesn't actually spy anything on the d
file
in fact all the important squares are
under control
so white could consider bringing this
queen to b7 or some kind of
square like that to start getting
aggressive or going after the pawns and
maybe there's queen a4
but then you give up the d5 square so
that's what is preventing
white from just pushing forward if you
ever move queen a4 queen b7
is annoying to deal with and bishop d8
can happen
protecting the pawn
okay so queen a6 check
queen f1 tempting but then bishop takes
a5 to keep calculating things like this
and it should be
completely fine for black but
yeah it's it's just not a risk that he
oh
i'd say not a risk he wants to take and
he does it so what do i know about his
risk aversion or not
so took on a5 queen f2 check
if bishop d2 is gonna play c4 that's his
idea
it's to try to get this bishop to b4
with a pin
wow that's that's really loud those are
sirens
really getting after right now hopefully
everything's okay
i assume it is but it's just
the life in new york city lyrical chess
i'm doing well thank you though so c4
king comes up to c3 to stop bishop b4
and the bishop before the king will take
you take the bishop and this pawn is
hanging
and white will end up a pawn to the good
so queen g1 hitting this point h3 should
be played and play quickly hikaru up
20 seconds so graduate will need to
figure out a way to
just make a draw either by some kind of
repetition or perpetual check
otherwise he's the one getting in some
serious time travels a queen a6 check
and the queen come back to a1
the king i don't think it really has
anywhere good to go
but the king is going to try to like
snake its way back
so king e3 can hear so
check on d1 check on f1 where's this
king going
king wait giving up the f4 pawn no no no
that's not what you wanted
queen back to attack this one this is
the second game that we've seen hikaru
really go like all in for the win and we
didn't take this pawn here that seems
like a mistake
but he's going for the win so much that
there
is some serious risk in what he's doing
and in the final game of the swiss that
was the game where
he was in a tough spot but was able to
offer and have a draw accepted against
demidov who probably should not have
accepted it
okay so now b5 or not oh the bishop is
hanging so no b5
and here there's bishop c5
stopping the pawn from pushing queen a7
trying to get down to a3 graja playing
really well
in time trouble here queen b6 and he's
just going to shuffle back and forth
that's the idea for black is not to do
anything of note this pawn on
h4 can be captured but g5 played and is
the idea to get this bishop here at some
point
bishop d4 okay queenie four checks nice
one don't take because there's bishop c3
wait what oh he missed queen d1 quinty
one would have picked up the bishop
okay so that's why the evaluation bar
just you know
plummeted there in black's favor the
bishop was lost
and now this pawn is captured bishop f6
check this king is not looking very safe
here king h6 was the only move to not
get checkmated
and here queen takes b5 is checked you
have to i think you have to steal that
pawn
i think you're gonna have to take that
pawn otherwise you're getting yourself
some big trouble here
so queen comes back king h7 somehow this
king isn't getting checkmated
it's surviving out here queen e3 bishop
moves somewhere i don't see where
okay bishop e3 will stop the queens from
being traded don't allow bishop g5 check
winning the queen so that's why the
queen went out that way
and we're seeing a little bit of a
repetition
bishop g5 it happened i said don't allow
it and there it happens
and hikaru nakamura you see boris gracia
is furious at himself he just didn't
have the time and ikaru
he escapes with one there so that was
really something and
um for
uh for god he has to go right away that
was
bishop g5 check hitting the queen and
the king at the same time
that's gotta hurt if you're grouchy so
here comes his attempt with the white
pieces he needs to win or else
he is eliminated from this bracket
and knight to c6 very calm setup for
hikaru
and you see the london you have the
triangle of pawns here
it's all safe and sound if queen to b3
you have to think do i really want to
trade queens am i going to be able to
beat
hikaru if the queens get traded beating
a car under any circumstance is
difficult
but in an end game probably even more so
all right i like that decision
to take on c5 if this queen were
captured the queen on b6 would have been
captured so now queen of b3 was played
and if you play queen to b6 i'd take you
and give you bad pawns
so so far i like what groucho has done
he's also a little bit ahead in the
clock
showing that he is comfortable in the
early stages of this game
so what what's he thinking about now i
was just saying how he was comfortable
and now
you know he's starting to spend some
serious time
okay he can castle he can put his knight
on e5 if he wants to trade it
i think 95 now makes perfect sense
because otherwise black is going to play
e5 and you won't be so happy about that
so knight e5 is just a way to
stop that pawn from pushing forward
and yeah there is a lot a lot of stress
in these games for sure
because you need to manage your clock
you have to realize you're playing a car
knock more that's already
tough enough as it is and when you have
no time
it's going to be a struggle any
suggestions on how to play london system
it depends if you're asking from the
white or black side of things
but in general it's hard to play against
london because it's so solid
there's no like square or idea that you
can exploit
too easily so do not take this pawn on
b7 rook to b8 wins the pawn on b2
so i would not go for that although it
is tempting to take a pawn
when it's handed to you so let's see
what can you do instead maybe just bring
this knight to
d4 although there is d4 for black to
consider so like if you go knight f3
then here comes d4
and you have to figure out if you're a
queen i mean this pawn things like that
are
kind of getting weird so queen a4 was
played instead to avoid d4
but a car was up 40 seconds more than 40
seconds on the clock right now
and i think that in a
standard game without elimination line
grasshopper would play queen to d4
and just trade queens but the thing is
that makes makes
it easier for black to simplify make a
draw
so here queen h4 well you're trying to
hope for some kind of attack will you
play g4 g5 you may need to risk
something like that or here even e4 is
possible because your rook is
well placed on the d file so queen came
back to e7
d5 e5 both defended really well here
you take on c4 good for you if you take
out the rook there's bishop b5 that's a
nice tactic
where i see through your rook to your
bishop and if you take with the bishop
on
c4 i'll just bring my rook to c it's a
normal position
i don't think that white's really in too
much danger but
black certainly is not and is over a
minute ahead on the clock
it's just too difficult to play hikaru
when he's playing
solid chess he has a one point lead in
the match and he is
so fast good luck beating in karu when
he is two minutes plus on his clock
just too difficult
too too difficult so queen b5
maybe poking and prodding a little bit
this bishop can always sit on e4 and
back to c6
to make sure that this queen on b5 is
not going to be much of a nuisance
bishop c2
i don't mind that move either it's
creating
some discombobulation of white's pieces
you want to make sure that they are not
connected together so rook to d2
hard move to play sometimes because
bishop b3 and then you get the
rook coming to c1
all this has just happened and now we're
seeing trades i don't know how you
expect to be takara from here
but i also didn't really expect a car to
beat garage in the last game the time
was what did it
but those side positions should be ones
where
it's heading towards a split of the
point
and here it's looking especially
likely that's going to be a draw
with the standard level of play we've
come to expect from these players
so here the queen on c3 the bishop three
they're both on good diagonals right the
queen is
hitting the e5 square the bishop is on a
long
diagonal but you're not attacking
anything and there's very little to
actually attack
this is a bit of a risk if the white
king gets in too quickly so
wait here comes king f1 knight d7 so
that knight's trying to come to b6 to
keep the king out okay hikaru had this
all under control because if that king
did jet itself
to c4 that could have been a problem but
here knight to b6
and the king can't get in
so f5 king of six these ideas keep the
white king out
and black should not be in any real
danger
so yeah this is looking like
just too solid too solid right now
for a car no way to break through
it's one of these positions that you
could say yeah it's looking like a
fortress
everything
is uh covered the c4 square the a4
square
and well losing with white against a car
in a two-game match that's
going to be a okay problem d6
so i don't really like the knight on d6
because that does give me the idea to
bring my king out this way
and if you ever play a4 then you allow
b3 and white gets an outside pass pawn
so all the pawns are dark squares
there's no way to get in on the
king side and now on the queen side the
king coming to b6 looks like
all is locked down very smart play by
hikaru on the
dark squares and you're against a light
square bishop that's the problem with
bishops they cannot attack pieces in the
opposite color
obviously and black is playing checkers
out here
with the uh hey they move
put the knight back on d6 so i can draw
the
checkers again maybe the king will come
to d6
like there's nothing that white can do
as these uh pieces
they won't let me do it it's just a draw
now easy easy easy draw
there's no way to even make a mistake
for
a car he just was king and his knight
and
yeah they drew so unfortunately for
boris groucho he
is eliminated hikaru nakamura goes up
one and a half out of two that's all he
needed to make it through
and so we will see nakamura on a shook
when we return from this
last quick break we will have the finals
ready for you we love vladimir onishuk
who
should not be underestimated he's an
extremely talented
speech us player has had feed a ratings
above 2700 well above 2700
so you know that he is a very serious
contender but hikaru nakamura
of course is the favorite so we're going
to go on a break now you see the people
leaving the
zoom call well that's my cue peace
everybody be back in a few minutes
for more the final of the speech
champion grand prix brought to you by
chess.com
[Music]
so
and we return here for the final it is
vladimir arnashuk taking on
hikaru nakamura and
we have onoshuk on camera
it is the last matchup of the day
these two players will be competing for
in the for the first place prize because
as you see here
first 750 second 400 not a bad payday
for either player
they will take home some of this money
here
and well we will have in
the first game hikaru nakamura
with the white pieces so he gets white
anashuk who was the higher seed
of the two players heading into the
knockout portion
he has chosen to play with the
black pieces in the first game probably
to know what he will need
heading into the second game right when
you play in a format like this you want
to know and do i need to win my
game with white or can i be okay with
this to draw and we have
liftoff here as you see the match has
started in hikaru with the white pieces
he just gets a strong center with pawns
in d4 and e4 the bishop on c4 the queen
on e2
this is looking to my eyes to be very
pleasant for a car and he plays
positions like this
from the black side too so he has great
experience a wealth of experience
in such a position and anashuk now
will play c6 i think and you can try to
play for d5
and that looks reasonable bishop g4
sometimes is played just to develop the
piece and say i know i'm going to give
him the bishop pair
but i'm not doing all that much so the
main thing for unesco i think is moving
quickly because we have seen what
happens in
other games when players have gotten
down on time against a car
so all right still very normal c6 and i
did come in d5 as i was
pressing h3 the bishop does not get to
g4 the bishop can go to the f5 square
but what is it really doing there like
it gets to f5 so what the bishop drops
back to b3
at some point if you do play bishop to
f5 i will consider
kicking you with g4 i would not do that
too early there's no reason to rush that
decision
but it's something that black often has
to be
alert for so now we've seen a trade this
gives the d
file to white at least in the current
position queen to c7 can be played to
get off the d file
but then white can just continue with
the development so
it's not really about any specific piece
in the position
it's that this bishop on g7 is i meant
that from white's perspective
is stopped by this pawn on e5 so that
makes the bishop limited in its scope
and for white you can say well my
opponent may want to go knight c5 to
attack my bishop on b3 so there hikaru
just went bishop to e3
you keep your opponent restricted make
sure that he doesn't have
easy plans easy ideas so you make the
move knight to c3 here just
continue the development what next for
anushuk i would consider trying to buy
knight b4 to d5 at some moment
but now after bishop f5 i would consider
a3 to take away that idea
rookie one hikaru says i mean knight
before doesn't actually
accomplish all that much because i can
still
perhaps just play a3 and kick your
knight out but i don't know something
about knight into d5 that looks
reasonable from black's point of view so
that's what i would go for
and i see plenty of people asking there
is no pog champ action today
so no no pog champs today
just the sec grand prix
and okay so how do i push e6 through do
i need to play and move like knight d4
first no i don't probably
e6 is so tempting because even if you
give up a pawn
i mean i can play g4 and just say well
good luck to your bishop
bishop here i can take and go knight g5
i mean just
directly attacking you
so e6 looks like one of those moves that
you're just
thrilled to have happen and
hikar is thinking and he ultimately
plays e6
and now with the pawn on
e6 you're directly throwing this pawn f7
just trying to break open the position
and you can take you can bring this
knight to d4 perhaps both are
moves knight g5 hitting the rook trying
to open up this diagonal
the one bit of good news for black and
there's not much honestly
is that the diagonal is hard to pry open
so you are saved from dropping a knight
or something because there's no pawn
going e4 or something like this
you'd have to move your knight then try
to play c4 and it's a long story
so look it honestly go brings his knight
to c5
very good decision attacking this bishop
on b3
also defending the e6 square which has
been vulnerable so this knight can take
on f5
but black's claim is like yeah so what
i'll take you back
and well maybe the pawn i guess is
necessary because this pawn is hanging
on e7
so bishop takes d5 and then rook to d1
now there is a threat of knight takes f
i really like how hikaru did not just
take on f5 he waited he said i don't
need to rush this decision
the knight md4 it blockades black's
entire setup
so i want to get this b5 pawn queen e5
is tempting
just trading into a good end game ah
this is nice
because the knight is protected so queen
b6 i just take queen c6
thank you for the a7 pawn this is not
the first time today
that we saw hikaru grab an a7 pawn that
his opponent didn't keep an eye on
we saw it against pragmata right there
was a bishop takes e5 knight takes a7
trick
and ikaru understanding that there is
a lot at stake in the center of the
board but this queen side also not well
defended so full board awareness by
hikaru
going from oh there's a d5 pawn there's
the a7 pawn
trying to keep as much pressure on his
opponent as possible so queen b8 was
played
and can you not just steal this pawn
with either the knight or the rook
it was taken and okay this is a hanging
rook just the knight moved out the way
that is game over on ashok loses rook
and
that is it hey karnakamor goes up one
game to none
so car off to a hot start in the final
he wins game one you see on a shook on
screen he's trying to figure out
what to do like what will he do
and we now are in the second game where
we have an italian it's going up into
infinity just because that's how
the last game ended and now we are back
to normalcy so the bar correcting itself
realizing that hey this isn't so good
for wedges just fine
so
here h6 b4
this pawn can go to a4 at some point so
i do like what unhook is doing here
because it's pretty solid
and i think that if this were
just any old game not a game where a car
just needs a draw
for any old game hikar would need to
press
to try to win do something a bit risky
but the thing is hikaru can just sit on
the position and not do much of anything
because the onus is on on ashok with the
white pieces
to try and win this game so a5 for
instance the bishop goes to a7 it's like
then what what's your exact plan you've
gained some space
and i'm all for that from a practical
point of view but how are you actually
going to turn it from a spatial
advantage a symbolic edge
into something that is concrete where is
there going to be a problem for black
and bishop back to b3 not really in love
with that decision
i thought that you know you're just
moving back and here d5 feels like the
right time
instead takes on either and then plays
d5 so if i
am on a shirt i'm thinking about just
bringing my knight into f5
your pony gets in first and the bishop
covers the f4 square
so negative 5 is a solid jump another
move that you should always consider is
c4
trying to force the action in the center
of the board and perhaps this bishop
will be better suited on b2
where it stares at the e5 pawn so
honestly does play pawn to c4
and now hikaru has a big choice do you
play c6 to reinforce the center
do you play d4 to close the whole thing
down and he chooses c6
at the end of this and i think that's
ultimately the right decision
but he needs to keep an eye on the
center especially he takes d5 and the
horizon
so let's see what is hikaru going to do
he is up plenty of time it's a good
moment for him to sit and think
he plays d4 it's a very committal move
so
the center is closed down which means
that white would like to refocus
his energy over here on the king side c5
says no b6 for you you're never
trying to open up this queen side
because you can't remember the rule
ambassador i could just
take it through and so the queen side is
closed this is a really good
illustration
of how to play these positions from the
white side i'm not at all claiming
that white is winning or even like that
much better here
but it's hard to play these positions
from black i've been on
the black side of positions like this
where you just don't have space and
don't really have a plan
whereas white's playing knight f5 g4
things like this it's very easy to see
how
white tries to push forward even if it
doesn't result in a win
it's just much easier to play and
especially in blitz
that's what you want that's really all
you can ask for
so the knight on c4 995 on great squad
bishop takes f4
take this piece and then play queen g4
oh
this is starting to look really really
excellent for
for white here because then you can play
e5 it's a cruncher
it's a cruncher bring queen g4 and then
play e5 where f4 the d6 square is under
your control
there's no space here for ikaru and on
demand
it's looking like anashook is pressing
his way here
because black has absolutely no space
in this position and e5 knight into d6
if you ever take
in comes a pawn to d6 that doesn't look
good
doesn't look good at all you'd like to
play g6 to kick this knight but h6 will
be hanging with check
so that doesn't work either
i don't even know how a car is going to
get out of this
this is a big issue for him and he's
down
almost 10 seconds now and the clock
keeps ticking because there are no easy
moves to play
for black here's e5 on a show strikes
quickly
he understands that my knight belongs in
the d6 square
where if you capture me in comes my pawn
if you don't capture me your pawn on b7
is in a tough spot and this pawn on f4
is also hanging
right now so anashu will either
win a pawn or
something like g6 will be played and the
knight can come into
d6 oh my gosh it's also 96 h6
that's a tactic g6 knight h6 and if you
take there's queen h4
winning the rook here so instead rook to
d5 was played
and i think it's about time to just drop
that pony in because b7 cannot be
defended
look at this setup here this
configuration is too powerful
oh this is objectively i think just lost
for black
yeah this is here the
sirens go you take this way do you take
this way
i think this bishop is in big trouble so
yeah this is what look at honestly go
take on f6 and when you take on e1 you
can go rookie 7 at the end and
down goes b7 rookie 7 now
very direct hit b7 that's the pawn you
want
because once b7 is captured you swing
your next rook over
and into e7 or you play rook to b6 and
just win some pawns
ooh g3 bishop takes g3 the one tactic
available to ikaru
and he sees these things so quickly
that's why he said
now g3 is possible so
got out of the way then played g3 all is
all is okay for anushuk he's up half a
minute
rookie four keeping things solid here
and winning this d4 pawn
rook to b6 now it's about time so why is
oh the reason we take this f3 point he's
just taking everything
he's taking everything and
down goes f3 now rook f5
king g oh don't under the b4 pawn but
look at this it was
the d6 for earlier now it's the b6
square
and the pieces just can't move this is
really just domination in this game
by ownership you got to give the guy
a lot of credit here he has outplayed
hikaru from
the very early stages of this game where
he sat he didn't create tension too
early it was hikaru created the tension
and then closed the center
and then asha quickly shifted his
attention towards the king side
and when the center opened up it was
only for his pieces
so
okay one sec everyone this is
and the rook's doubled he comes broke
back to f5 that way he doesn't give the
g3 pawn
he's not giving a car any counterplay he
could have taken on
the pawn but he didn't want to give him
his g3 pawn just look at the position
it's actually only one extra pawn for
white but it's plus almost seven
at this point because black can't move
okay this is the one chance that akara
thinks he has
makes sense to me i wouldn't be
surprised if the rook backs up to win
this pawn but it said the knight
retreats
so where's this knight going so rook f3
is the threat so he goes knight to d2
onishok is all sorts of prophylactic
today rookie 6 takes c6
take on a6 take everything take it all
don't hold back knight e4 can always be
played once the bishop moves
that's a good try though bishop f4 if
you took the rookie two check
everything is safe and sound he gave the
car
no chances this was an exquisite
performance
from honestly he wins with white we get
ourselves well
we're gonna have ourselves a little fun
here
we are having ourselves
some fun we have tie break
i'm waiting to hear who has
which color but i'll start with a blank
board
anisha played a
kind of a perfect game he really did oh
and the action has already started so i
don't even
have time to wait honestly gets the
white pieces he needs
wait does he need to win this game
wait i think it might be two games of uh
let me
let me refresh my knowledge of things
going on because i was saying armageddon
and i realized that
no this uh it's just a single game here
so i guess it is kind of armageddon but
it's not
black black does not win with a drum if
they draw they keep on going
and the car is already out to a fast
start here he's up eight seconds he's
played
so he gets the d4 square and now this d3
pawn is going to be a permanent weakness
so that's a big issue for honestly
because he tries to
continue this game here his bishop on c2
is just a massive pawn
it's not doing anything with staring
into your own pawns so it's not really
helpful yet but d4
he's moving backwards to get after the
a3 pawn but at some point he was
should consider pawn to d4 to open up
the bishop knight c3 bishop b1 he wants
to keep his pieces
knight back to e2 he's going to play d4
king f3
okay or knight g3 d4 still a possibility
but he's refrained from playing it
and it's pure bullet so hikaru is
obviously the favorite when it comes to
bullet chess
and anushka is trying his best he
finally decides to open up the position
but he's losing his pawn on d4 so this
is just
a great turn of events for hikaru he
kept the pressure up
he's now up a pawn and he can just move
his king he's up 10 seconds
hikaru nakamura is taking this one
and yeah this is all the dark squares
under black's control
up 10 seconds here so you but you can't
make a draw right and draw still
allows the match to continue
and this is just the knight getting in
here that's a problem you can take on h4
now he's defended six 19 seconds to
four no no no not enough time
not enough time and it looks like
hikaru is just taking this one he's
ripping
all the pawns off the board and
he just doesn't care he wins the time
that's game over
that's match over so that means we have
a winner
of today's speed chess championship
grand prix it is
hikaru nakamura no huge surprise there
when he wins an event like this but he
does
take home the first place prize to
remind you of what that was
it was you know just a little bit of
money there seven hundred fifty dollars
he'll take that vladimir andershuk
well he's probably not thrilled about
what happened in that final game but
he gets himself 400
so can't be too upset i'd imagine
um it's just the way things go right
you play a car nakamura he often wins
the games
so hikaru wins the
final and
takes home the grand prize takes home
the grand prix points not that he really
needs those
and for anushka it was a great
performance by him just to take
hikaru down to the bullet and i am
to remind everybody here that we
actually have something special for the
audience
where we will have an interview
a hard talk interview with feed a
president arkady
dvorkovich and jessica had a chance to
sit down with him this morning and get
some answers about the olympiad
and fide from the best possible source
so it's from
defeated president himself we will hear
what happened
and what the thoughts were in the
decision making process of the olympiad
giving gold medal
to both india and to russia so that will
be shown
right after this we have a great
interview in store for you all
but in the meantime it's been my
pleasure i want to thank everybody who's
been tuning in i see so many people
right now um watching this stream it's
been
so fun for me to get back into
commentary after taking a little bit of
time off just to
uh refresh to recalibrate to uh just
get myself back in the mindset i wanted
to be
in order to commentate it has been a
blast for me i
love covering speedchest events bullet
is immensely fun as well and whether
you're watching on
chess.comtv whether you're watching on
twitch or on youtube on facebook
wherever you've been watching
this stream i'm very appreciative of all
the support and all the
uh support for chess more broadly but it
was a car nakamura's day
i didn't want to take don't want to take
center stage anymore so
with that it was hikaru who ends up in
the first place so congratulations
to him and
well he takes home the
grand prize of 750
and with that i think i'm about to head
off
to let you all watch this interview let
me just confirm
with my team just to
make sure that i can do that
and
okay so well
i'm being told that it's just about my
cue to leave shortly
the interview will be on next so
you will have a chance to listen to
arkady dvorkvich as he discusses
what happened in the olympia so i'm
heading out thank you again everybody
hikaru nakamura wins vladimir and shook
was a worthy contender finishing
in second place the runner-up despite
taking hickor
all the way down to the bullet finale
interview up next i'm out of here you
have to listen to me talk so enjoy the
rest
of your tuesday and until next time it
was grandmaster robert has with the call
this was the chess.com speeches
championship grand prix
hope to see you next time everybody
so
[Music]
you